erica take us back to you're moving to
los angeles and i believe you booked
your first tv show just two weeks after
moving to l.a
[Music]
yes
um
so i
get obsessive about my goals and my
dreams
obsessive i think it's a good thing
although it can border on
unhealthy
and i knew that i wanted to work in
television i wanted to work in hollywood
and so before i moved to la about six
months prior
i started researching people to connect
with
and i really
like i think i emailed about 150 people
cold email
i would watch the credits after a movie
i would look on imdb
you know for tv shows that i enjoyed and
look up people who were doing what i
wanted to do which at the time was
graphic design and i
would cold email and message people and
so
that is
really what helped me
book my first tv show so quickly because
one of the contacts and now granted out
of 150 maybe three people you know wrote
me back or were helpful so it wasn't a
lot of people but
one of those contacts ended up being
very helpful actually maybe two
but one person
really connected with me and it helped
that he was a little younger he was
closer to my age and so we sort of
connected as friends and that really
helped and i always tell people you know
when you're
trying to make connections in this
industry work on making friends you know
really try to think about it as you're
connecting with people that you can
genuinely connect with because those are
the people that are going to be so much
more open to helping you
so that's what happened so i i connected
with this one guy and he was very nice
and i came out to la two weeks two weeks
a month maybe before i was gonna move
to look for apartments and i ended up
showing him my portfolio
so that he could kind of you know get an
idea of my work and then when i moved to
la the very first week he gave me a test
like a test project to see how i do
under pressure and you know if i can do
this you know designing graphics for
television
not that it really requires super
different skills than designing graphics
for anything else but
the pace is different and you know
they're going to be looking for
something specific so
um
he gave me a test he actually did pay me
for it which was really sweet so it was
on a show that he was working on and he
gave me one of the graphics and said
here make this logo
um
and i guess i passed the test because
the next show that he was offered he
couldn't take and so he recommended me
and then i got to interview
for that show and and then i booked it
when you went back after looking for the
apartment and you i'm assuming you flew
back was there any doubt that maybe you
wouldn't come out or you were ready to
go no
it's so interesting to look back at that
time
because i look back and i think like why
weren't you more scared or why why
didn't you have more doc i was so
obsessed i had done
in high school i had done a summer at
ucla
and i did their intensive theater
program and so i had already spent some
time living in los angeles and i
was enamored with it i just thought la
was glamorous and you know
everything that the movies make la out
to be i joke about it because at ucla
we weren't really allowed outside of the
ucla radius on our own
so i was like la is so beautiful it's
like well
westwood yes erica
did you see hollywood or downtown um
but um yeah i just i was so
my heart was pulled to this city it you
know i just knew that i needed to be
here so no and and actually
when i was supposed to move to la the
week before i developed a disease in my
eye
and i still have it to this day
and my parents were like
maybe you should push off your move like
a month or so let's get this figured out
and i said no
i need to be out there now i started
building these contacts they know that
i'm coming in a month no i will get an
eye doctor out in la
and that's that's what i did so i was
determined
and not only that but it was 2008 yes so
the economy was
unraveling yes things were turbulent yes
i didn't really feel the effects of that
until 2009 because i moved towards the
end of 2008 and booked that first show
so quickly and then this first show
we did a season and then it was canceled
and so after that show was cancelled and
then i was unemployed
it was almost like because i booked that
show so quickly i didn't have time
to be super confused and alone in la yet
because i had worked so quickly and then
um after that show was canceled and the
economy was crashing and it was
incredibly difficult it was the worst
year of my life i mean
i really struggled
right and i know i think you've talked
about that in your book and we're hoping
to maybe cover that i just want to go
back to one quick thing and i think that
is
is is that something you expected to to
book a show so fast or because you had
the one contact who seemed dependable
you you felt that was
something that was definitely going to
happen i mean is that normal to get
something i mean i don't think i had any
expectations in terms of time i will say
you know that's something because i was
so
uh passionate about my dreams of working
in television i never
considered a time frame i never said i
need to make this happen in six months
or i need to make this happen in five
years you know a lot of people
uh give themselves a deadline and
in my mind i never did so i never had
any
timeline expectations
um i was just so excited to be in la i
mean i was also terrified once i got
here and i didn't really know people
here so i was very alone i mean it was
it was a pretty challenging time and i
was absolutely terrified in the
beginning but
i was i just knew that i was excited i
knew i wanted to be here so i didn't
really have any expectations of when or
how it was gonna happen
what if it's been five or ten years
and someone's not any closer to their
quote unquote dream and they come here
from somewhere else
i think that question
has nuance
because i've worked with a lot of people
who have been here for five or ten years
who feel
nowhere near their dreams and who are
really struggling
but
if we're really honest
it's not like absolutely nothing has
happened in five or ten years
so maybe they're not where they want to
be yet they haven't booked that big tv
show yet if they're an actor or you know
they haven't booked that big project
whatever
their craft is
um
but it's very i don't think i've ever
met any artist out here who literally
has not
done a single thing in their career in
five or ten years unless they got a day
job that became their sole
you know priority and then they just
worked on let me get a promotion at my
day job let me try to move up here and
and that becomes the priority so the
only time i've ever seen like literally
nothing happen is when the day job
becomes the priority over the dream and
they kind of let the dream go for all
those years
but of my clients that i've worked with
i think it's important
to celebrate what you have achieved and
to take like even if you're not where
you want to be and it's been years
take a look at what you've actually done
even if it feels small to you
because i think that um
if you can start shifting your focus
onto what you have done instead of what
you haven't it'll help you feel more
confident it'll help you feel
you know just better energy you'll feel
proud of yourself you'll feel
better and so
i think that will lead to
more things happening um now that being
said you know when i work with people
there's so many things that we can take
a look at like you know why are you not
where you want to be yet and so we can
take a look at
what are the strategies that you either
haven't tried at all or that you have
been procrastinating you know that's a
big thing
um or that
there's so many pieces sorry i feel like
this is gonna be a long answer but
there's so many pieces to it it's like
with the strategy piece it's like
are there things that you haven't tried
and then if there are let's take a look
at why right and that all comes down to
your belief system the fears that you
have the doubts that you have whether or
not you believe in yourself um
and and that can get very nuanced as
well you know we get deep into what is
really truly holding you back
from
doing some of these strategic moves that
you really haven't done yet
and then another thing that i've noticed
with some of my clients
is that the longer you have been in the
industry
and i always say hollywood but i don't
say hollywood as in the location i call
like the industry hollywood so the
longer you've been in hollywood if
you've been in hollywood for five or ten
years
you end up having more limiting beliefs
than somebody who is brand new
because someone who is brand new
they're so green and they're so naive
that they take more risks because
they're not afraid of doing the wrong
thing because they don't know what the
wrong thing is
whereas someone who's been here for a
long time and has been in the industry
for a long time you know more about how
the industry works and you might know
more about like behind the scenes and
what relationships are important and
what you need to be doing
and then because of that you you lose
your sense of
risk-taking and being bold and putting
yourself out there you know
um in a i hate to say in a risky way but
it's all about risk-taking you know it's
all about putting yourself out there and
taking risks and so
the longer you've been in hollywood
the more rules you are trying to live by
but the thing is is that for every rule
in hollywood there's always an exception
so
you don't necessarily want to use these
rules to hold you back
and when i say rules just for an example
in the industry
you know some of my actor clients when
they are wanting to they need to get a
new agent or a new manager
one of the rules in hollywood is you
should never contact representation and
reach out to them during pilot season
right there's like certain times of the
year that's busier maybe the beginning
of episodic or you know when pilot
season is going on and you're not
supposed to reach out
right and so it's just because you know
how the industry works you've been in
the industry a long time you know that
there's a pilot season you know that
people are really busy during pilot
season
but there's always going to be an
exception to that rule that rule is not
really set in stone
and so if you follow that rule because
you think you're you know you have this
knowledge about how the industry works
and you want to
be good and follow these rules that you
think you know
in that process you are stopping
yourself from taking a risk
and i've had many clients book agents
during pilot season and then are able to
go out for pilot season
so that's just a little example you know
of i think some of the things that hold
people back in hollywood the more they
know
the more it tends to hold them back
and then also with that
there's a third part of this that i've
really noticed with some of my clients
is that
the more you know
the more boxes you try to fit into
and i feel like that's just a big thing
in hollywood that a lot of people
struggle no matter if you're a writer a
director um you know working behind the
scenes somehow an actor
you know even my production designer
boss a couple years ago fell into that
of like how can i you know oh i do drama
and they don't think i can do comedy
and so
i have found that a lot of people get
stuck in these boxes because they're
trusting other people to tell them
what box they fit into
you know like with actors it all
all starts in the beginning with
headshots i've seen this so many times
where an actor is told to put their
headshot on facebook and ask everyone on
facebook what what roles can you see me
as with this headshot you know what
shows do you see me in according to this
headshot
and that's a super common thing right
and if they're not asking their facebook
friends they're asking their agents
their managers their you know their
teachers
but every time you do that you are
asking somebody else to tell you how to
live your dream
and you're letting somebody else dictate
what roles you go out for what projects
you get to be a part of and you
completely lose your voice
and so i think that when people struggle
in the five to ten year range i think
that that sometimes depending on the
person you know plays a part where all
these years maybe they've been trying to
pursue the industry in these boxes that
they were told they should be in
but it never feels good and it never
feels aligned and so they struggle you
know i have one of my clients really
struggle with that and you know she's
done such beautiful work as we work
together for the past two years and
she's really come into
her own right like you know she's really
connected with
who she really is now and who she wants
to be and not who hollywood has been
telling her to be all these years
and then that leads to more exciting
opportunities because you're more
confident and standing on in your own
um
more often and you know that will bleed
into the work that you do even though it
sounds counterintuitive like oh erica
but hollywood loves the boxes
stepping out of that is somehow going to
help you succeed
i think yes i think it's about
alignment and and being yourself a
hundred percent i think that will always
lead to more success
i love what you're saying
what if what if we can't accurately see
ourselves because like i knew someone
who
was was auditioning and she was doing
well and she was about to turn 30 which
when you look back at it from an older
age is not old at all but a friend or so
she thought said oh let me see your
headshots
and so she showed this friend and the
friend said oh and he gave her this
feedback he said look
you're getting near 30 so you're gonna
want to aim for mom rules
so maybe tone down the sexy factor a
little bit and
that was sort of eye-opening to this
person because they still saw themselves
as this
you know not sex kitten but they just
saw themselves as not as the mom
and so i'm just wondering how much is it
that we're blinded by ourselves because
we can't really see ourselves accurately
sometimes
or
was she allowing this person to really
tell her how to be
yeah i think i mean it's a great
question and and i'm sure that you know
every agent or casting director or
whatever will disagree with me but i
think that
the more we
buy into the boxes the more we are
helping perpetuate the problem
and so i think that
you know with the rise of streamers like
netflix and and hulu and amazon we are
getting to see more complex stories
which is amazing because with the
networks of abc nbc you know those are
likely following formulas that have
worked before and they're a little more
of stereotype when it comes to
characters and content and you know and
story
but
because there's so much more content now
available with the streaming i really do
feel that we are finally moving into an
area of hollywood where we are getting
more complex storytelling and so to me
like the mom right you turn 30 and then
you need to play the mom it's like could
you be a super complex character that
happens to have a child
right and so i think that we need to
stop
letting hollywood define us as the mom
um
even if that feels hard you know even if
you feel like you're getting the advice
from someone trusted who's been in the
industry i think it is partly on us
to stop perpetuating
those kinds of things that happen you
know
like the client that i was talking about
she just came out as non-binary
and that can be really scary as an actor
you know because she's having to explore
with her representation what that means
in terms of what roles she wants to go
out for
but
to her for her to even have that
conversation with her representation
she is breaking through
the the boxes and the hollywood stuff
you know of stereotypes and she is
challenging it because she is saying
this is who i am this is who i know that
i am
and so let's explore what kind of
complex roles i can play
so
i guess to answer your question about
you know
finding ourselves if we feel like maybe
we've lost ourselves i think
you have to begin by tuning out
everything
tuning out the noise don't listen to me
don't listen to other people you have to
get back to yourself
and
what your dream truly is you know the
very first chapter of my book
i invite people to write down
everything they would love to happen in
their career everything that you dream
of you know get back to
that dream you had in your heart when
you were a kid or whenever it was that
you decided you wanted to pursue this
dream get back to that
and connect to that and really you know
some of my clients too they'll
they'll study they'll do some research
and watch you know some shows that they
really love and start to explore what
excites them you know when you watch
this do you feel really excited because
you'd love to play a complex role like
this person
um
so
i think that process involves you know
you
um
reconnecting with your own intuition and
tuning out the noise and get really true
to who you are
and decide
that you are worthy and are capable of
succeeding as who you are
even if others tell you no you need to
play the mom or know you need to fit in
this box
erica what's the biggest obstacle you've
had to overcome in your own life that's
a good one
my biggest obstacle for sure that i have
had to overcome that i'm still working
on
is my self-worth and you know my
struggle with self-worth
um
i've done a lot of work to try to work
you know to try to heal that and and
work on that and i think that
being an artist in hollywood
requires you to put yourself out there
in a way that most people won't really
have to do in their lifetime if they
weren't pursuing a big dream you know if
they weren't trying to do something um
challenging
it requires a lot of you
and
you know
through you know with rejection and and
also through depending on what your
job is in the industry what your craft
is
it can feel so personal you know like
what you are putting out your work that
you are putting out it is like you right
it's attached to you so i think that
you know
i tend i tend to attract a lot of
clients who are like myself and i think
a lot of artists in general struggle
with self-worth more so because it's on
display
so much more often than maybe other
people
who aren't working in an industry like
hollywood would have to you know face
essentially um which i guess it's a good
thing it's a good thing that we need to
that i should say i that i need to work
on this and that i need to
um get better but it's really been
my biggest obstacle because i think that
it impacts everything i do it impacts
how i put myself out there how i ask for
things that i want if i you know
come across as
someone who believes they're worthy of
what they want or you know i talk to my
clients a lot about
how a lot of artists come across as
desperate in the please choose me please
choose me am i good enough tell me i'm
good enough and i think a lot of us you
know struggle with that so i i myself
have struggled with that as well um and
i think especially shifting into my
coaching business where i have to build
a business on me where i'm the brand and
um
it's it's been a whole extra
layer of me
working through some self-worth
stuff i guess you could say but that's
definitely been my biggest obstacle
i'm wondering if
struggles with self-worth actually
propel someone to go pretty far because
when i've done like little bits of
research on a lot of people whether it's
acting music whatever i find a lot of
them have a missing parent
and i think that that causes people to
do interesting things and so i'm
wondering if that almost propels people
to to go further where someone
who doesn't it's more safe and so
oh okay i didn't get this well that's
all right but somebody who really is
like obsessed with it
it actually that that
self-worth sort of wound
actually makes them rise up more i hope
i'm i'm making sense now you're making
perfect i mean tony robbins talks a lot
about the idea of
if you grew up
without a lot of
trauma or obstacles or issues you're
almost in a worse spot
trying to achieve big goals
um he's you know because because of
exactly what you're talking about this
like safe comfortable kind of bubble and
and a lot of people you know look at
people like oprah who had an incredibly
challenging childhood right so a lot of
the times that people who grew up with a
lot of obstacles or potentially a lot of
trauma it does propel them you know it
does um ignite a fire perhaps or or
helps them succeed i think with
self-worth particularly it could totally
go in that direction
but
i find at least with the clients that i
work with is that more often than not it
actually does hold people back
from taking bigger risks or putting
themselves out there in a bigger way and
so they do it kind of in a safe way of
yeah and i myself
struggle with this and i know that i can
catch myself when i do this you know
sometimes i'll you know
make a post for my business or something
and i'll do it to an audience that i
know already loves and accepts me and so
you know i think that
if you if you doubt yourself
and you don't feel worthy of what you
want
it usually ends up holding you back
so like if people procrastinate
procrastination is really has nothing to
do with laziness and everything to do
with resistance and a lot of times when
people procrastinate it's really truly
because they don't feel worthy of the
thing that they're trying to make happen
um so i do feel like you know i think it
can definitely go in the direction that
you're talking about and i think other
obstacles and trauma absolutely does
propel somebody forward but a lot of
times with self-worth it it it holds us
back from you know going after the big
things that we want
right yeah i'm thinking of like marilyn
monroe
and
the lack of self-worth probably took her
very far but it also could have taken
her down unfortunately yeah i mean i
guess too you know if you don't have a
strong sense of self or strong
self-worth
you're going to let a lot of people tell
you how to live your life you know tell
you you know back to these like
hollywood boxes like like for example if
you don't have a strong self-worth maybe
you do end up booking projects booking
shows booking um features but
none of them feel aligned like you don't
actually feel happy you feel miserable
right because you let somebody else tell
you what you should feel or what you
should go after because you didn't feel
that you were worthy of the things that
you really want
so tony raw i i guess i maybe i have
heard that from him before but so you've
heard him say that it's actually
not an impediment to have had if having
had like sort of this safe
upbringing but
or maybe it is i don't know yeah i don't
want to i don't want to butcher his
words and say it incorrectly
i'm just i'm just recalling you know my
memory of what he said
but that was that was like i have
remembered that because i
you know it's interesting like i am
someone who is incredibly determined and
ambitious
um
but i i did have somewhat of a
comfortable life and sometimes i wonder
if
that propelled me actually this is like
a totally different topic but if that
propelled me in a way where like i feel
less scared to go after certain things
or to take some risks because i feel
like
i i still have a safety net of my family
like i have a good family life you know
so i feel like i still have this safety
net so maybe it's less scary for me than
other people but
i don't know from what i remember of
what he said
um
i'm pretty sure he did say that you know
people that
that struggled more
in their childhood or in their lives
kind of have that
one up on
i don't know maybe being ambitious or
pursuing your goals
what's the biggest challenge you've
helped one of your clients through one
of the biggest challenges that i have
helped my clients with
and this probably doesn't sound very
sexy but
i feel like i i feel very fortunate
to
connect with people who
are struggling in their careers and are
really down about it
um and the fortunate part comes with how
i get to help them not that i'm so glad
that people are struggling that maybe
came out wrong but um
i've been very fortunate to connect with
these people who
feel really down about their careers
because maybe it has been some time and
they're not where they want to be yet
and so sometimes people come to me where
they're depressed and they're really
feeling down and by the end of the time
we're working together
they they feel happy again they feel
excited again in their career you know
they feel hopeful
and that energy switch
is so
crucial to what comes next in terms of
their strategic moves and what
opportunities come their way like it
really does help them bring in a new
level up opportunity and
so i think you know like i've had
clients who are on the verge of quitting
and i'm like one of their last resorts
you know and so i think for me that's
one of the most
challenging things that i've helped
clients with but i think that is so
rewarding because it's so
it's so awesome to see people who've
started feeling really down and really
depressed about their career who now
like one of my new clients i mean we're
only like a month in and she's already
feeling so excited and hopeful and
that is just so awesome i mean you know
i just feel so fortunate to be able to
help people
like i feel like one of my superpowers
is helping people believe in themselves
and and really seeing what's possible
and so i feel honored to kind of relight
that spark for people and help them get
back to
what's possible and and get back to
their dream
well it's like dating you know like when
you're in a relationship all of a sudden
now all these people are attracted to
when you weren't yeah no one would call
no nothing happened but then all of a
sudden you give off this energy of like
i don't really need it that much or
whatever and i think that yeah the
desperation goes yeah something happens
and whether it's dating or business or
whatever but i don't know if the same
for
some of what you've talked about i mean
a little bit you know it's it's a to for
me it's about the energy and so and it's
about getting in alignment with the
energy of the thing that you desire so
if you're feeling really down and really
low which is normal and happens all the
time
you're not likely to attract you know
exciting new opportunities right it's
like if if you're feeling like really
low
and you're right here
um
and these opportunities that you want
are up here you're not in alignment with
them
and
and so when you start to feel good again
and inspired and excited it brings you
up here and now suddenly you are in
alignment with these new opportunities
and i think from like a slightly more
tangible way to explain this
is that when you are feeling really down
and really low
you are
problem oriented
right and so and i i know that i've been
this way when i went through my really
challenging year 2009 and i was really
depressed my mom would suggest
solutions to me and she would think of
ideas to help me and i would say no to
everything i would shoot down everything
i was just not in the energy of
accepting help or accepting a solution
because i was feeling so low and so when
you're feeling hopeful and excited again
suddenly it's like oh there's
opportunity everywhere i see solutions
everywhere
so
you're my you know the your belief
system and your energy it's all
controlling
the opera like opportunities might have
existed around you the whole time but
you just didn't see them you know i
always talk about the example of the
fedex logo do you know the fedex logo
um so i mean i would know the colors
it's like the purple and the orange and
you know that there's like the hidden
arrow
in between the e and the axe of fedex in
the white space maybe i don't no
so i say this because a lot of people
tend to know about the arrow and and so
if you don't know about the arrow go
look at the fedex logo and so it's in
the negative space the white space
between the e and the x
um and that was intentionally done
because fedex is about you know movement
and
so
there's also
a little hidden baking spoon in the
lowercase e that most people don't know
really okay and the idea is that
even if you didn't know about that arrow
and that baking spoon they were always
there
you might have looked at that logo a
hundred times and you didn't see that
because you didn't know it was there you
didn't know to look but it doesn't mean
that they didn't exist they were always
there
so it's like when you are feeling
hopeful and excited and you're feeling
good
you know to look for opportunities that
are always around you
but if you're feeling depressed and low
you're probably not even going to see
them even though they might be right in
front of you
what do you do for people that they
can't necessarily do for themselves
two things i think one is like i talked
about i think that i help people believe
in themselves and believe in what's
possible in a way they never have before
i feel very proud i feel like it is my
superpower you know to really help
people
expand their view of what is truly
possible
and the other thing that i do that
people might not be able to do for
themselves is to see their blind spots
right so
i can usually have a conversation with
them and fairly quickly
determine where their blind spots are in
terms of like what's holding them back
you know if they talk to me about their
strategy you know i can pick out
what's really holding them back in that
strategy
what the limiting belief is you know
just the other day i was on a podcast
interview and i was coaching the
the
one of the hosts and he talked about how
him and his producing partner they they
live
somewhere else in the united states and
they're working on moving to las vegas
and
and they had this whole plan about why
that was a good decision
and i said tell me why you're moving to
las vegas instead of la tell me why
you're not moving to la
right and so
they told me all these reasons that were
really fear-based they didn't believe
that they could afford to live here they
didn't believe they'd find any work they
didn't you know they they have all these
stories that they decided on
um
that created their decision and then
that decision leads to
dream adjacent
right and so i think that um we can't
always see our blind spots that's why i
work with coaches too you know i have
people help me with my blind spots
and so we can't we can't see them on our
own you know because our mind is really
good
at justifying our decisions
our mind is really good at coming up
with reasons or excuses about why what
we're doing
is the right thing to do or the best
thing for us but a lot of times you know
we're holding ourselves back
and so i help people
with that and and really helping them
recognize where their blind spots may be
how do you define success
my definition of success has changed
over the last two years and
i would not be surprised if it changed
again in the next coming years i think
that
for the last
10 years i really define success
by
the projects i was booking and the money
i was making
and
once i got those things that i desired
then i realized
wait a minute
i really just want to be happy
not that some of those things didn't
make me happy but
now i'm really
chasing for lack of a better word
what makes me happy
and
and that's to me more important i think
that
i'm still
weaving
into my you know one of my coaches was
like oh so you say that's what or maybe
my therapist said this you say that
success is just about what makes you
happy but you're still kind of
living in this world where you want to
make a certain amount of money and you
want to book certain projects and and so
i think that i have one foot in that
world and one foot in this world but for
me
it's so much more about
being happy
and helping people
and so i'm i'm trying to
refocus my energy
on that because i think it's really easy
to get caught up especially in the
social media world where we're comparing
ourselves to other people all the time
and what their lives look like and where
they're spending their money and what
projects you know i think um
you know a lot of my actor clients we
talk about how
their least favorite question ever is
have i seen you in anything or are you
working on anything now
people feel very insecure about that
question and so
i just you know
i myself have gotten very caught up in
what projects i'm working on so that i
can tell other people and then i will be
perceived as successful and being
perceived as successful is more
important than how i actually feel
doing these things and so
um
so now i'm just trying to let go of that
and focus on
what makes me happy like i think that
you know it's like if we look back at
our lives i don't know i would rather be
happy and and doing things that feel
good and excite me than constantly
worrying about trying to compare myself
to others and what it looks like to
other people
what do you think about the fact that
that's a great place to be in but some
people might need to have
kiss the ring so to speak and then
realize you know what it wasn't that
great and i actually just want to be
happy but they needed that
experience to know i actually was up
here for a little bit and
i decided
i wasn't happy but i needed to know what
that felt like
yeah i think that
we all are on our own journey we all are
on our own path you know if i had to
experience that to learn this lesson
it's not even necessarily a lesson it's
just a redirect for myself
um
and so i i don't think there's anything
wrong with like some people just have to
live out their journey and live out
their own experiences than to decide
what they want you know i think that's
what we're always collecting data based
on how we feel so everything that we do
we're collecting data and then we're
re-evaluating so i think that's totally
okay but what i do
sort of direct people in my book is to
and again this is something that i feel
like that i've been working on is to
stop setting goals that are based on
validation
right so
try to at least start chasing the joy
because i think that the all those
things that you think you want they're
going to come anyway right you can be
happy and get all those things but we
don't necessarily always know why we
want those things and so i think it is
important to take a look at like well
why do i want that you know like i
remember i have a dream of buying a
house it used to be in the hills but now
i want one in the palisades or you know
with ocean view as opposed to city view
and i remember someone said to me oh do
you want that because of how it'll look
and i said oh my gosh no
that that's not part of this dream for
me at all i want it because i have
family back on the east coast and i want
rooms for them to come visit for
extended periods of time so that i can
be you know i'm very close with my
family and i hate that they're so far
away and i don't get to see them very
often
and i'm also very sensitive to my
surroundings that i want surroundings
that inspire me and excite me
and so it's really what it's about and
so
i think yeah i think
if you're feeling like well i want the
money or i want
the accolades
it's just about getting really
honest with yourself about why you want
those things
everything that we say we want
is because of how we think we're going
to feel when we get it
so if you you know if you want an oscar
why why do what do you think you're
going to feel when you get that oscar
and and i think that if you can break
down those feelings it's more important
to sort of chase those feelings or to
try to feel those now
than necessarily the the label that you
think is going to give you those
feelings
um if that makes sense so i think you
know like i said in my book it's really
about like set any goal that you want
there's nothing wrong with any of them
but if you're chasing them for
validation to make you feel good to make
you feel more worthy or more deserved
deserved deserve it
it probably isn't going to feel the way
that you
think it's going to feel it's not going
to solve the inner problem right like
none of the external things that we
create for ourselves or that we get
aren't going to are never going to solve
an internal
problem
i think most of this is is validation
from others or self-validation
validation from others
you think that matters more to most
people i think a lot i think a lot of us
make decisions based on
how others will perceive it
how like for example
everyone and their mother in this
industry says that they want to work on
netflix you know on a netflix project
and
you know there might be some
like there might be some reasons behind
that
in the terms of well they do great work
you know they they tell complex stories
and i'm interested in the stories that
they're telling
but a lot of people especially the
actors that i work with or the directors
the writers
they say they want netflix because
netflix is a huge well-known entity
right now
and if they book something netflix they
can then post it on social media or they
can tell people
hey i booked a netflix show
and that makes them feel successful
because they're perceived as successful
because it's a network or streamer that
everybody knows
right but
what if what was really important to you
that you booked a project that told a
meaningful story
that impacted people's lives and that
was really fun to create and it felt
really great like you were working with
great people collaborating with great
people and the whole experience just
felt good
well what if you could get that
experience
at abc
or on hulu or you know or another
smaller now you know because i talk
about one of my best experiences in
hollywood was a show that was on abc
family which is now free form you know
and i don't think many people
are like i want to work on freeform like
everyone's like i want to work on
netflix you know it's not maybe as sexy
maybe they don't have quite as many
viewers but
it was the most fun i ever had
on a show and we were telling a
meaningful story and there were really
amazing crew and cast members
it was just a really good experience
so
yeah i think that it's
this is a long way to say i i think it
is about chasing validation from others
and how we are perceived by others
and does that go back to sort of that
boxes thing that you said like being in
la you you
think that there's these certain rules
in these boxes and it's the same thing
about like oh
oh you're just doing the um the score
network
i've never heard of it yeah oh okay yeah
no but if you were somewhere else
oh wow you're on a tv show how cool
right but here there's these levels
right the hierarchy yeah yeah i i don't
know if it's necessary i guess the box
is in a way where you're like boxing
yourself into what your dream has to
look like
like my dream has to look like me
working for netflix um so i guess in a
way but
i do think yeah that people
don't realize
that
it's probably going to be a more
enjoyable experience if you
intentionally try to create
a good experience for yourself you know
like a show that you love working on
that you're doing meaningful work then
whatever the label of the network or the
studio is you know because you know look
like i've i've known series regulars who
have quit
and who just like after a few seasons
weren't feeling fulfilled anymore it
wasn't like a story they felt like was
meaningful in their lives you know and
so that happens you know like you might
get the thing that you think you want
like you might get netflix
and then it not be a good experience i'm
not trying to put that out there i'm
sure like there's a lot of amazing
experiences on netflix but my point is
like get clear about how you want the
experience to feel and what you want the
experience to look like like i say in my
book like write make a list of
everything that you want in the next
project you want to book or whatever
goal you're working towards write the
list of everything that everything you
think netflix is going to give you
right write down everything you think
it's going to give you and then
take away netflix at the top
and then but still but still chase your
list
right so you're still really going after
what you truly want but you're allowing
it to look however it looks
how do you help people with the part of
success where they want what other
people have
i mean that is
happening all the time and i have found
myself
um getting caught up in that too you
know i think that
when people post things on social media
i think that's like really a lot of
where it comes from as opposed to seeing
it in actual real life i think that when
we see somebody's highlight reel on
social media
we are
putting a whole story behind that post
about what it means and how it must feel
for them to have what that thing
right so
if somebody posts a picture of
themselves
uh driving a porsche you know a fan's
very fancy car
and they're smiling in it and they're
like yeah you know they look cool
you might then create this whole story
about
what that means for that person and how
their life must be so amazing and it
must feel so good for them and wow they
have so much money and we create this
whole narrative about what it means when
we see
them having this thing and we're like
well we want those feelings i i want to
feel
financially stable i want to feel
wealthy i want to
um feel excited about a new purchase i i
want to have a car like that right so we
we
think that they're feeling a certain way
when they have something
and then we want to feel that way and so
we think
the way we feel it is to try to get the
same thing they have
and it's so easy to get caught up in
whatever we think
you know
people are
or whatever we're seeing people have you
know even if it's a a booking you know
if you book a job or you have an
audition or something you know i think
that
if you see someone post online that
um i'm trying to think of something that
maybe i've
thought i wanted but i didn't actually
want like like
for example one of my clients
said you know what they're an actor and
they were like you know what
every actor wants to be series regular
they think it's like hitting the lottery
you know financial lottery because it's
it's a lot of money and it's consistent
work
and
one of my clients was like you know what
i don't think i want to be a series
regular at this time in my life like
because you usually have to wake up at
like four in the morning you know you're
there all day it's a very long day you
have to wake up she's like i don't know
if i really i kind of like waking up at
eight o'clock and said you know i don't
know if that's really what i want in my
life right now
so she had to you know get honest about
wait a minute what makes me happy what
would make me happy now
um
so i think social media plays a big role
in it but but it's really what we decide
it means
right what we decide it means that this
person booked this project or has this
opportunity we also don't know the truth
about what it means to that person or
what they're really feeling on the other
side of it you know maybe
they're like posting i i had this
amazing audition for this for netflix
wow i'm so lucky i have such a great
life
but really they're feeling like maybe it
was like a
two-line role and it was something that
they're not actually excited about but
they're trying to tell the world that
they had this netflix audition and then
people that see it are like oh man they
have this great life they're getting
these netflix auditions and then we
create the story about what we think
they're feeling or what you know
so
i think it comes down to
what are the feelings you want to feel
when you get the thing you want
and stop assuming that every single
person who has something feels that
exact way because i think we're
attaching those feelings to what other
people have
how do you help clients who are hyper
focused on other people's achievements
i help them get reacquainted with what
their true dream is
i think it's so easy to look at what
everybody else is doing and to decide
that that's what success means and so
that's what i should go after
but we really want to reconnect with
what our true dream is like what is it
that we truly want like
tune out the noise stop looking at what
other people are doing stop looking at
social media what people are doing on
social media what they're posting
and really reconnect to what is it that
you truly want you know i have this line
in my book that i was actually really
proud of i think it's a good line where
i said
when you are trying to replicate someone
else's magic you are taking yourself out
of the running for your own
and i i think that's so important i
think that as long as you are chasing
somebody else's dream or you're trying
to you know have or do what other people
are having and doing
you are cutting yourself off from your
own fulfilling really cool journey you
know really amazing magical experience
you know
it's going to be so much more fulfilling
if you reconnect to what it is that you
want and go after it in a way that feels
good to you
as opposed to comparing yourself to
everybody else and trying to replicate
what other people are doing i think as
long as you are trying to replicate
somebody else's path you're going to get
stuck
i i think we all have our own path and
we we need to find our own path
especially in an industry like hollywood
where there's no one way to do anything
you know if you lined up 10 successful
people or 100 successful people
and ask them how did you break in or how
did you get to where you are you're
probably going to hear a hundred
different stories
so
it's important that we leave room for us
to find our own story and that comes
from really letting go and disconnecting
from
what you see everybody else doing
what's your definition of a high
achiever
i that's such a good question um because
i use that term all the time
um my definition of a high achiever is
somebody who
first of all has a desire for something
beyond
the base level
you know
like people say oh i want to be a
working actor
and i'm like really like that's such a
base level thing i understand you want
to pay your bills from acting and sure
that would be amazing but like that's
one aren't you you're gonna want so many
more
things you know beyond that so i think
like number one it's about
the desire the desire for something
greater than what's comfortable for most
people
and then i think that you know a lot of
my work in terms of
helping people become high achievers is
about how you think about what you're
doing what your belief system is behind
what you are doing
so that it leads to higher level risks
higher level actions and strategies that
then
usually lead to higher level
opportunities
but so you know in my book i talk about
the 10 pillars of the high achiever and
it's
it's really about how you view what is
possible
and
um
[Music]
how you view what you're capable of you
know what you're able to do so
if you're a high achiever you view the
world in a way that you believe that
anything's possible
and you
make decisions based on your desires and
based on your dreams instead of based on
fear you know you do things that are
not based on those hollywood rules you
know you really
go beyond what i call like the most
people pool so you're not doing what
most people are doing
um you're doing
what the smaller pool of high achievers
are doing which is you know you're
really you're really looking at the
world in a different way and and your
own dreams in a different way like if
you have a dream of winning an oscar or
being a millionaire
you believe
that not only that it's possible but
that it will happen for you
and just that belief
changes that it changes the entire
trajectory you know of what
what potential you have in front of you
so base level let's say filmmaker
screenwriter what would so that would be
they want to work on a few projects not
they're looking to i mean like
maybe my working actor example wasn't
the greatest because i'm definitely not
trying to judge anybody's like level but
i think that
you know like beyond student films
beyond unscripted you know we're talking
about hollywood for for screenwriters or
for any other
kind of craft you know i think that
um beyond what most people
strive for you know because i think that
striving for like a base level keeps
people safe
you know i i think that most people that
have dreams of succeeding in hollywood
in this industry they have their dreams
are beyond
student films or their dreams are beyond
you know
just paying their bills you know i think
a lot of people dream of telling really
interesting stories you know i think
people love storytelling and the art of
storytelling you know a lot of the
people that i work with they want to
make an impact on people's lives they
want to make a difference in the world
through storytelling you know i think
that that goes beyond i just want to be
able to pay all my bills
from my craft i think everybody wants to
be able to pay all the you know bills
from their craft but
um i think the high achievers they want
more they want to they want to go beyond
that they don't want to stay safe and
comfortable
at whatever
level is safe and comfortable
what are some of the
achilles heels of a high achiever
interesting question
one of the things that i personally have
struggled with and i consider myself a
high achiever
is
all like the fact that i'm kind of
always reaching for something
right and so i think that that might be
an achilles heel of the high achiever
where
that bar is always moving and and so
that
like one thing that i've been working on
is being more present
you know being more present in where i
am
and trying to enjoy the moment
because my eyes are usually always on
the next thing you know i'm always
reaching i'm always on that next thing i
always want to know my next goal you
know right now i'm in this period where
i don't really know for sure what that
next goal is for me and i've
never experienced that before it's very
uncomfortable to have to just sit here
and be present and wait for it to sort
of
come or be inspired um and so i think
that's probably
a high achiever's achilles heels that
you know they're not really sometimes
struggling with being present and
enjoying the journey and enjoying where
they are because their eyes are always
on the next thing
is there no other way around that
as a high achiever is that just part of
the journey so to speak yeah i mean i
don't i don't want to put my own
struggles on anybody else and make a
blanket statement and say that you know
all high achievers will you know
struggle with that i think everybody
we all have our own stuff you know
um
so
yeah i think you know everyone's going
to have their own struggles but it's
really about
how
willing are you to do the work to better
yourself
and to get where you want to go
how do you train someone to believe that
their success is inevitable
i drill it in them a hundred times until
we believe it
i think that whenever you're trying to
take on a new belief sometimes our
subconscious mind needs proof
and so
i try to
tell people
what that means in tangible terms like
why is your success inevitable and
what will happen if you don't believe
your success is inevitable right like if
you don't believe your success is
inevitable
it is very likely that you have a plan b
you know that you have some sort of
backup plan that you have set up a
timeline for yourself where if this
doesn't happen in five years i'm gonna
move back home or i'm gonna do something
else
um right you're coming up with like
insurance because you don't believe a
hundred percent it's like a prenup for
your dream because you don't believe 100
that it's going to work out and
what happens is that when you don't
believe your success is inevitable you
don't take the big risks you don't put
yourself out there in the same way
because you don't believe that it can
happen right so it really impacts the
strategy or the actions that you end up
taking
so
i try to help people by showing them
where you know where their current
belief
of not believing their success is
inevitable is leading them and how
that's playing out and i like to inspire
people to show them like why i think
their success is inevitable and i think
that if you can take away the lottery
feel
of succeeding right because i think that
you'll hear often oh succeeding in
hollywood that's like winning the
lottery so for example one of my clients
i think this is in my book
she said that that was something that
she had heard a lot you know that
good luck trying to make it in hollywood
that's like winning the lottery and so i
said to her
can you count on your hand can you name
any people you know who have won the
lottery
she was like you know i don't think i
know anyone who's won the lottery
i said okay
now can you count on your hand and name
me people who have
succeeded in hollywood
and she listed like 10 people that she
personally knew who were doing well in
the industry
and so you know because we want to give
our subconscious
brain the subconscious part of our mind
some sort of tangible proof to hold on
to and so when we go through that it's
like oh okay so it's actually not as
hard as winning the lottery it's not
that random
because i i can name so many more people
that have succeeded right so suddenly
your subconscious goes oh okay that's
different
so
we start looking for proof
of why like why is your success
inevitable like why is it inevitable
that you will succeed well if you
take a look at you know all the people
who are successful and who are you know
if we take a look at their actions or
everything that they've done and if
you're doing the same things it is
inevitable that it will lead to success
and that success might look different
to every person and however you define
success
but um
you know i really try to help people
retrain their brain to understand
that succeeding in hollywood doesn't
have to be this
insane unlikely thing
you know i think that we kind of come
into it with that notion
and so we want to train our brain to
understand that that's not actually true
do you think some people might want to
fail because it brings more sympathy
more people like you
if too successful people won't like you
i that's an interesting question i've
never thought of it that way i think a
lot of people want to fail
because
if their subconscious mind does not
believe that they can succeed if they
fail they're proving it right
and people like to be right
so they like to say see
told you i couldn't succeed right and so
like i always used to give this example
sorry i'm giving so many actor examples
i work with a lot of actors but
um
you know
if you
don't believe that you 100 are going to
succeed as an actor
you might take a day job that is a nine
to five
and if you have a nine to five day job
you can't really audition i guess now
it's a little different during the
pandemic with self tapes everything self
tapes right now but
you know pre pandemic and hopefully post
pandemic auditions will be in person
again and they're going to be during the
day during the week right and so if you
have a nine-to-five job
you're taking this on because you think
you're doing the responsible thing and
we could talk about day jobs is like a
whole nother conversation where we can
have where a lot of people have an idea
in their mind that the only way to
financially support themselves is
through nine to five work
but that's like a self-sabotaging move
right and so then
you're not getting auditions because you
can't go on them unless you're calling
out for a doctor's appointment every day
and then you end up you know a couple
years in and you're not succeeding in
hollywood and then you can go see
i was right i'm not succeeding in this
town in this industry so
i think that um
people self-sabotage just to like prove
their subconscious mind right
um but there's there's so many reasons
why people want to fail that some people
are afraid of success they're afraid you
know kind of what you're talking about
are they afraid of like not being liked
but also what does that mean in the
dynamics of your family you know what
will your family think if you succeed
what does that look like um
you know
how will you feel if you're quote
unquote more successful than your
parents or you know someone that raised
you or something you know people
struggle with so many nuanced things
about
failing and succeeding so i think there
are many
reasons but those are a few right or or
maybe if um
the the brother or the sister was always
the golden
child and then the black sheep actually
surpasses it yes
that that's a taboo
no it's not okay
yeah there's that's interesting
people will be afraid of success like
that because we would think oh no no
that will not i'm that wouldn't happen
to me no i just
you know yeah and some people think that
if i do succeed there are other things
in life i won't be able to have you know
like if i'm successful in hollywood i
won't be able to have um a happy
marriage and raise kids you know people
have that fear sometimes of like you
know the scheduling with hollywood that
i won't be able to
have a family things like that so
sometimes people self-sabotage because
they're afraid that
even if they do succeed there are other
things that they won't be able to have
or that it'll you know negatively impact
relationships
that's true or the nanny will know my
kids better than right yeah right
what are some examples of star qualities
star qualities
i think
one of the things that i outline i have
a whole chapter called star power
chapter two
one of the examples that i give in the
book is when you think about
someone who is a star like taylor swift
or steven spielberg right so it's not
even necessarily a star as in they're a
performer and they're in front of the
camera
someone that's a star in their industry
who were they before they had any
credits
who was taylor swift before anybody knew
her name
she was taylor swift right and so i
think it's about
how you show up in the beginning
and i talk about you know
like we all have this greatness within
us and you don't need a resume or an
imdb credit or any other kind of
validation
to prove
that you can be a star you know that you
have greatness i think that we all have
greatness already within us and so
you know star power is about
embracing that connecting to
your own star power that you have before
a single person knows your name or
before you have anything on your resume
you can still have that star power but
it's about
showing up as a star now
before waiting for somebody else to
validate you and to say that you are a
star or to say that you are great um
it's about believing that in yourself
now before you do anything
can you give me an example of a star
quality that seems that's kind of
unknown that would be unlikely that you
would never think that
you know we think of someone with just
amazing confidence owns a room
head turner in so many ways
charming
i think that
for me it's it's not even about
necessarily those things it's a well the
confidence piece it's about the it's
about owning your dream
owning what you want and deciding you
are worthy of it
because that will
translate to risks that you take in
actions you take the example i give in
my book is about steven spielberg and
about his story about how he
you know basically broke in he
was able to get a meeting on the
universal studios lot with chuck silvers
who i think was working in post
and
he got to connect with him for three
days
and he was so excited he got to be on
the lot and i think he got to show him
like a short film he had made or
something like that
and chuck said okay well the three days
are up you know i can't get a pass for
you to come back onto the lot you know
if you want to come back you'll have to
kind of find your own way i can't get
you like a permanent pass
so
steven spielberg was like
all right i need to get back on this lot
i need to connect with these people i
need to show them my work i need to get
in front of them
so the next day he shows up in a suit
holding a briefcase
goes up to the gate and just waves to
the guy at the gate
and it looks like you know has the
appearance of working there and they
just let him in he didn't have to show a
badge that would probably not happen
today because you really do need to have
a drive on
today but
what i love so much about that story is
that he was taking a risk and being
incredibly bold to try to create
opportunity for himself and he didn't
wait until he had jaws on his resume to
feel confident enough to do that you
know he didn't wait until
he was the steven spielberg that we know
because i think it's easy for people to
go oh well he's steven spielberg he can
do that but he wasn't that steven
spielberg that we know when he did that
so
for me it's examples like that it's like
how do you show up in the beginning do
you show up and take bold risks
you know showing up like you are
the star now you don't have to wait
until someone else deems you a star
to
to take those kinds of risks and and
take those actions
i like that so sorry again it's knowing
that start like owning your dream and
saying that i am worthy of it yes and
and when you feel that way
what risks do you end up taking like you
know what i mean i think that a lot of
people in steven spielberg's position
would never do something like that until
they are at
his now known level of success
right somebody won't feel comfortable
taking that big of a risk
unless they already felt validated by
hollywood
you know like one time
nothing ever really came of it but
there was some tv show filming near
where i on location near where i lived
and
i saw the prop truck and it was open and
so i brought my business cards to the
prop truck and there was no one there
and i just left my business cards on the
floor of the prop truck you know so it's
like it's like things like that it's
like how how do you show up like can you
be bold and show up in a way that most
people would never do unless they
already felt validated by the industry
that's a great story
yeah i heard about someone else who had
a business card and they were mad and
they were in real estate and they're
just like forget this and they threw
them all in a parking lot and someone
found one and said i have a house to
list amazing right yeah
you know look i mean like not every bold
risk is going to be received with open
arms but if you're not taking those
risks you're never going to get the
potential opportunities that could come
from them
right
right because you know it this is a town
where you know there's all these pretty
people and and their accolades and and
people are bragging and and they don't
want to stay small they want to just
kind of like peacock feathers and i
think it's easy
to be in a room whatever your thing is
and and hear that from the side and
you're like
i i what am i doing here
you know and then but i like what you're
saying that if you just all you have to
do is just
say i'm owning this is what i want to do
and i'm worthy of it and it doesn't
matter if this person
you know has this beautiful plumage that
they're kind of showing the world
i i my thing is also going to matter you
have the plumage too it's just not
visible yet like i i really believe that
we all have that greatness inside of us
i think it's internal i think you know
the plumage that you're talking about
comes from like external
you know imdb credits or you know
prestige or celebrity or whatever but to
me it's a hundred percent an internal
thing it has nothing to do with the
external and you can have all those
external things and still show up and
feel imposter syndrome you know and not
feel worthy of being in the room that
you're in and and that happens you know
all the time too look at you know child
stars you know a lot of times where it
doesn't it doesn't pan out as they get
older because it's like too much too
soon they weren't ready for it mentally
right and so maybe they felt like an
impostor or whatever there's a million
different
reasons why that happens but it's like
you know 75 of lottery winners end up
getting going broke and again it's like
this whole idea of like they weren't
internally ready
for the thing so to me that plumage that
you speak of is really truly internal
and not external
erica i have a composite of someone i'd
like you to have coach cool so
we'll give her the name of crystal
and she has wonderful ideas which she
puts in notebooks she's written five
screenplays
but
she ultimately feels like an imposter
especially since she hasn't been able to
get any producers
interested in her work and she's had no
luck with screenwriting contests
her goal is to be a hollywood
screenwriter
crystal has always done incredibly well
at everything she's undertaken she's a
perfectionist somewhat competitive but
her sense of self-worth is wrapped up in
always being the best and always winning
which she's usually been successful at
she's feeling more and more that maybe
her work isn't creative and interesting
enough
and it's not original possibly so she's
feeling useless and maybe that she
should stop quote-unquote wasting her
time trying to pursue this career but
she doesn't know what else to do
so how would you begin to work with
crystal
crystal let's do this
um
well the very first question i would ask
her and i do have a process that i take
my clients through that i'll share with
you but the very first question i would
ask crystal is do you want to quit
right she's talking about potentially
throwing in the towel she doesn't think
her work is getting her where she needs
to go or where she wants to go and so
she's considering doing something else
is that a true desire
or is it i don't feel like i'm good
enough i feel like i failed therefore i
should do something else you know i
think i joked with one of my clients
because the other day she had a moment
of like oh i want to quit you know i
think so many of our artists feel that
from time to time on their journey
and then um
last week she got a very incredible
audition opportunity and she was really
excited about it and she put so much
work into it
and
my whole comment to her was oh so you
don't want to quit
[Laughter]
so i
i but so i it's like somewhat of a
rhetorical question because i think i
know the answer is like no i don't want
to quit but i do think it's important
for someone to say that out loud you
know to someone for someone to really
be honest and come to terms with what
you truly desire i mean if you truly do
desire to quit and try something else
that's okay too but then we don't need
to work together right so i think number
one is
really
asking crystal is this something that
you want to keep doing like do you still
have that whisper is that dream still
calling to you
is that why you're coming to me probably
you know so
i think that's like important to
establish right off the bat
and then before
we dive into strategy and what's working
and what's not working and what are new
strategies you could be doing
i spend the first
usually hour and a half with my clients
on
what
is their belief system what are the
fears and doubts that are really holding
you back and i actually go through this
in my book as well you know my book kind
of goes through a lot of the things that
i do with my clients so the first thing
i will ask crystal is
what do you want
so you say you want to be a hollywood
screenwriter what does that look like do
you want to sell scripts do you want to
be a staffed writer on a show do you
want to be a show creator
what does that really look like for you
like what is your dream do you want to
be winning emmys you want to be working
on features and so
i want to hear about it i want to
reconnect to her dream i want to hear
everything that she wants and i would
ask her like write a bulleted list of
everything you desire
and we're just going to put out of our
heads right now that maybe we don't
think it's possible we have no idea it's
not really happening just put all of
that out of your head right now i just
want to know what do you want
if you could have your dream what is it
that you desire because once we get
really clear on what it is that she
wants that can really help us form a
better strategy that's going to be more
tailored to what she actually desires
right instead of creating a strategy
based off of
what other people are doing right i
could easily go oh crystal you want to
be a screenwriter here's the
screenwriter path let's do this
no i want to know what are her specific
dreams maybe she even has specific
dreams of
certain types of stories or certain
genres you know like i've worked with
some screenwriters who are super into
the horror genre and that's all they
want to do so i want to hear about it
and so once she writes this list of
everything that she desires
then i go okay now tell me every doubt
and fear you have about that list
and we really need to examine
what are the beliefs in your mind right
now in relation to this dream that
you're trying to make happen
because that belief system
is going to control what you do next or
what you've been doing
right you know like for example when you
said
she hasn't had any luck with producers
my question would be how many did you
ask
if you don't believe your success is
inevitable
that list is probably five to ten people
long
my clients are emailing 250 people
right and so your belief system behind
everything is going to control
the actions you take and then
inevitably the opportunities you get
from those actions you know like a lot
of people and i i've struggled with this
myself um
a lot of us we stop short because we
think it's not working or we feel
rejected or we feel discouraged and so
we're not really
going the extra mile you know we're not
really taking those risks we're not
really doing everything we could be
doing
because we feel deflated
and that you know those discouraged
beliefs
um they will impact
the lack of action that's happening so
i would take her through
uh that list and i would want to hear
what what's every default fear it's
gonna say fear endowed in the same word
what is every fear what is every doubt
that comes up for you when you look at
this list
and then
we take every fear on that list and we
flip it to create an affirmation so that
your new belief system becomes the
opposite of what you believed
so for example if crystal's like well
i have a fear that this will never work
out for me
okay
what do you wish you believed
well
i'm being crystal here well i
wish that i believed that it would
definitely work out
okay
that becomes the new belief
my success is inevitable
right and so we're flipping the fears
and so then at the end you have these
two lists side by side you've got all
the fears and doubts and then you've got
the opposite
you know essentially affirmations of the
new beliefs
and i always say when you look at these
two lists side by side if you looked at
them as two different people
person a and person b
what kind of career would person a have
with this list of fears and doubts
that's their belief system what kind of
career do you think they're going to
have
and it's usually well they probably
won't get very far they're probably
going to struggle
and then what about person b these
affirmations this new belief system what
kind of career do you think they're
going to have
and
you know it's usually they're going to
kick butt they're going to do great and
and the whole point of this is not to
say you can never have these fears again
you know i think the doubts and the
fears they're always going to be there
they might change over time but
the point is we want the second list to
be in the driver's seat so the fears and
doubts it's okay to have them they're
still going to hang out in the back seat
of the car but we want the affirmations
the new list the new beliefs driving the
show
and once you build that foundation and
you really get clear about the belief
system that you currently have and you
know the belief system that you really
need to move forward then we can start
to examine the strategy then i want to
know like crystal okay tell me how many
producers you've reached out to tell me
how many agents and managers you've
reached out to have you tried to get
representation tell me you know tell me
about i want to hear everything that
she's done and we can take a look about
okay well here's what i think a better
strategy would be for you based on what
you told me you desire right and then we
can build a new strategy from there but
what i find you know especially you said
that crystal is perfectionist and i just
got to do a clubhouse the other day with
someone who specializes in perfectionism
and i really learned a lot um you know
perfectionism holds us back
it's definitely one of those things that
holds us back you know what we fear
and she was saying a lot of times it's
also tied to self-worth like we
we think that we're only worthy if we're
perfect if our work is perfect
and if i feel like
my work isn't perfect then i'm not
worthy and if i never put my work out
there or take the risks with my work
that i really need to be taking i don't
have to confront whether i'm worthy or
not
right so
tying your self-worth to perfectionism
we would dive deep you know into all of
those things and
take a look and you know the other thing
i would say i just wanted to add because
you mentioned the festivals
there is no one way to succeed in
hollywood
right and so if festivals is one door
that you're knocking on it's okay
if it's not leading anywhere there are
still a million other doors that you can
knock on so i don't think that any
single door is the be-all end-all you
know we don't have to create the story
in our mind and that's what we do when
we have a rejection we create a story in
our mind about what it means so i would
want to know hey crystal you haven't
succeeded with festivals what are you
telling yourself that that means
so you know really diving deep into
how you feel about what's been happening
and and how we can work on changing it
if that makes sense
it does do you think people that fail
are too busy saying no or to be busy
saying yes because you know how shonda
rhimes talked about she had a yearbook
yeah and i think that's great so so but
but in some ways you could say yes to
things that could give you busy work too
but do you think as a rule though most
people who failed they haven't said yes
enough
i don't think i don't think i would cat
like i usually don't like to make
blanket statements over things like that
i call it absolutes you know saying all
ways or never because i don't think
anything is the same for everybody um so
i think some people have trouble saying
no and some people have you know trouble
saying yes
and it just you know
has to do with your specific situation
you know i had a client who had she was
an actress and she already booked a lot
of television she had like 50 or so
episodes already under her belt
um at the co-star co-star recurring
level maybe one or two guest stars i
forget
maybe it's just all co-stars and she
really wanted to work on her next level
and so we worked on she ended up getting
new representation but one of the
biggest things i worked with her on once
she got this higher level
representation
was saying no to auditions
and really getting clear about what her
next level looks like and
and what she wants to say yes to and
what she doesn't want to do anymore you
know what was part of her old level so i
think i think either way i think people
hold themselves back with the yes and
the no
would you ever tell anyone that they
weren't talented enough to do something
professionally i would never
tell someone that they're not good
enough
never
because i had somebody tell me that
in high school
and
um
[Music]
what i have learned
working in hollywood for now is like 13
years
talent is only one piece of the puzzle
it's one
piece
there are so many other qualities that
you need to succeed outside of talent
and i think that
if you care enough
talent is always something that you can
work on you know craft you get better
through practice and so you can always
be in class you can always be working
with a coach like there's so many ways
to get better in terms of your talent
um
and
from a law of attraction standpoint the
law of attraction doesn't care if you're
talented or not and i hate to say that
because i don't want to discourage
people from taking their craft seriously
but have you ever watched a tv show and
thought oh that acting wasn't very good
or that writing was ooh terrible you
know or listen to a song on the radio
and thought i feel like i could sing
better than that person you know my
point is is that
talent is just one
piece and to me that is not
a deterrent if you're not the most
amazing at your craft yet
i think that you can still win i think
you can still succeed now from an
integrity standpoint i think you should
be working on your craft you know
from an integrity standpoint i think you
should care about your craft and you
should work on it and you should
practice you know i think some of the
greatest artists in history are people
that
did it all the time you know they
practiced all the time so i think you
should absolutely be working on your
craft
um
i just think that there are so many
other qualities that you need to have
out like i talk about this in my book
where i say
you know going back to crystal even you
know if you are cold emailing
representation and you're trying to get
representation
if you email 20 people and they either
all say no or just don't even respond
your talent
is not going to get you to keep going
it's your perseverance it's your drive
it's your desire and your ambition right
there's so many other qualities that you
need to keep going in a moment like that
so i think that your talent it only gets
you so far and if the talent is the only
thing you have
it will most likely be a hobby and not a
career
so
i i just i just will never tell somebody
that you know when it's when someone
told it to me
it's happened twice actually to me and
it was really soul-crushing you know
even in design school
when i i tell the story it's the first
story i tell in the book so sorry to
spoil this but
um
you know when i first got to art school
or the design program at the college i
was going to
i did really well on the first project
and the second project i
almost failed
and the teacher said
oh i guess you just got lucky on that
first one
i will never forget that i mean i bawled
my eyes out i ran to the bathroom and
cried and i just thought wow like my
mentor this person who's supposed to
teach me how to be good is telling me
that anything i've done well so far is
chalked up to luck
and that was like so soul-crushing for
me
and then i went on to
have a pretty incredible graphic design
career in one of the hardest industries
to work in in hollywood and i've worked
on over 30 television shows so i ended
up transferring schools
uh because it just it wasn't
that style of teaching wasn't for it
didn't feel good for my growth you know
i didn't feel like i was learning
anything or getting better and i just i
don't like using fear as a teaching
tactic but
the point is is that i was told that i
essentially wasn't good and i still had
an incredible dream career after that
you know i think that i got better i
learned how to get better and teachers
told me how to get better you know and
they taught me and they mentored me and
and i got better and plus i had all
these other qualities
that go so much so far beyond talent
were they trying to use like a tough
love style of like tearing you down then
to build you back up sort of thing was
it that
no it was really you know no because
like i don't think there's really
anything wrong with tough love i mean i
guess delivery could be debated but
um tough love is really like telling you
things that you you need you know you
need to hear that you might not want to
hear
but will help for your growth and so for
me that
program was using fear as a teaching
tactic
and so like
and i know that a lot of the other
students felt the same way we were kind
of scared to go to class
what is the teacher going to think what
are they going to say there's so much
fear
um you know even with that assignment
um i didn't get any notes as to like
what could have been better
and so i didn't so i'm like oh i'm
almost failing this project but i don't
actually know how to make it better i
just feel bad about myself and i'm
scared because it's t like this
teacher's
um you know
like instilling fear in me essentially
in the way that she taught and she did
that throughout the whole semester
so i just i didn't even like at the end
of the day i feel like i was learning i
was like i want to be a good graphic
designer but i don't know if i'm
learning that here
um
and it was interesting because almost
every student felt the same way but i
was the only one that left
so
again a very teachable moment for myself
you know
but
yeah i don't i don't love some people
like that teaching tactic to use fear as
a teaching tactic i i don't for me it's
not productive
i feel like i can learn how to do better
and be better without
being afraid um i feel like it doesn't
create like or foster a safe environment
to take risks and fail
so
that was my personal experience
but then how can we
deliver a message to someone without
being
um without protecting them too much
where
they're almost blinded
because we're not
giving them the real
[Music]
i don't know i mean there's like yes
people yeah a lot of times i'm sure when
people reach a certain level they're
surrounded by yes people
and i don't know if that's good or bad
probably some i don't enable them yeah
yeah i don't think that's surrounding
yourself with yes man i don't think is
ever
good at least for growth
yeah
i think that i mean feedback it's
totally okay to give feedback you know
um
that teacher was more like
you bad you know it wasn't like
constructive
feedback that i felt i could learn from
so
um you know the art school that i
transferred to was very tough very tough
um but i never felt
bad about myself i don't know it was
just constructive feedback it was like
well this isn't working so well here but
if you do x y and z i think it would
work better and here's why and then i
would go oh that would make this better
let me do that you know then i'm excited
about making changes
because i'm learning why it would make
it better which i think is really
important and you know as artists
it's
important to
not attach your self-worth to your work
um you know your work can be a separate
thing um
yeah
what it going to that second art school
that you said was very competitive
teach you
um
in terms of competition i should close
well i
i wouldn't say it was necessarily
competitive although they're what well
there was a little bit of a sense of
competition they they ranked the top
five portfolios when we graduated so
you know there was something about like
oh are you top five and
and and i wasn't in the top five but i
had a professor tell my mom oh she would
have been in the top seven if we did
seven she was in our top seven
and
it's like like but what what does that
actually mean like i've lived such a
different career you know i went off to
design graphics for television other
people are doing other things so i think
that
i think what it taught me is that it's
good to strive to be your best
but you don't necessarily have to strive
to be the best because i think the best
is going to be subjective no matter you
know where you are what pool you're in
so
you know
it's it's good to just strive to be your
best you know do better than you did
last time you know see your own growth
and then let that
lead to your own path you know even
looking sometimes i would compare myself
to
um where my other
um
peers are now you know with their
careers or you know we had a couple
students from our school
one that is she graduated the year
before me i believe year or two before
me and she became a pretty famous
graphic designer she's very well known
she's a very big following and the
teachers love that and would always
point out you know talk about her and
use her as an example of course and then
it's like oh and i'm always trying to
like we would joke about
her name in class my peers and i because
it was like oh we're never going to live
up to
that person to our in our teachers eyes
and
so i i guess i learned
in that sense about you know
like like stop
i i want to tell myself that even now
because even now with my book i'm like
still trying to impress my professors
and i graduated like 13 years ago and
i'm still like do they think i'm
successful do they like what i'm doing
um and
yeah but i think that lesson i learned
there was really like
let yourself be on your own path and you
know just compare yourself to where you
were before and stop trying to be or do
what these other people have
is competition good in that it prepares
you for the real world because in the
real world there's no oh you did great
and oh you get a good gold star it's
usually much more brutal than that and
it can be very cold
unfortunately yeah definitely i i just
have a slightly different
belief about
competition i believe there's room for
everybody
and that might mean something different
it doesn't necessarily mean there's room
for everybody in the same exact seat
right but
i do believe that we all deserve to live
our dreams in our own way so
um
it can be competitive in the real world
or even in school
but
that doesn't mean that you can't live
out your dreams you know someone beating
you out for a job or an opportunity or
something doesn't mean that you can't
still live a fulfilling life or achieve
your dreams i mean there were jobs that
i did not get you know i interviewed
i've only interviewed like four times
maybe for a tv show most of the jobs i
got came from connections that i built
over time
the only times that i've interviewed
i've never gotten the job
never
and
that didn't mean that i couldn't still
have a really great career i mean
someone else got that job over me right
so in that sense in the competition i
failed there or whatever someone beat me
out
but there was another show for me there
were more opportunities for me you know
so i really believe and chelsea handler
talks about this too you know she says
like there's room for everyone
can you talk about the other time that
someone said you
wouldn't be able to do something or
succeed yeah technically
they didn't say the words but it was
implied and it was something that i'll
never forget in high school
i
was very involved in
drama and chorus
so i was secretary of the drama club i
was president of the chorus that was my
life i loved singing i loved acting
not the best at dancing
but i wouldn't i would do what was
required but that was my life you know i
lived theater
and i did pretty well you know
i was up for the lead several times i
understudied the lead my sophomore year
i was actually up for a lead it was
between me and one other girl my
freshman year which you know was a big
deal in the politics of high school that
being a freshman up for a lead
and
um
i you know i i did well enough to be
decent you know i wasn't the star of our
high school or anything like that i
wasn't in that like top elite group that
was like really phenomenal but i was
pretty good i was good enough to you
know get a leading role in a musical
once and and some other big parts and
other opportunities
and
i loved
theater i i really loved acting i was
more enamored with hollywood than
broadway but
i really loved it and like i said i did
a summer program at ucla and it was a
summer theater intensive so i actually
went to ucla for acting
when i was still in high school
and
when we started applying for colleges
i
didn't apply to any acting programs
and a lot of my friends did
and
i i started discovering my love for
graphic design
during that time and so
i was feeling pulled toward graphic
design and so that was really what i was
working towards getting into for college
but
i was still in the mid you know i'm
still in the midst of theater and i sat
down with my the theater teacher one day
and it was just the two of us in a
classroom
and i looked at her and i said
you know
the reason why i'm not pursuing acting
in college is because i know i'm not
good enough
there was like that little girl inside
of me that so badly wanted her to say
you can do it you're good enough like
give it a try if that's really what you
want to do go for it
and she didn't
and she just sat silent and didn't say
anything
and to me that was confirmation you know
of her saying yeah well you're you're
not the star of our program and it's
only the stars that really go on
and
you know that was so many years ago and
i remember that moment so clearly still
all these years later it really had an
impact on me and
it was one of the reasons
you know why i didn't pursue acting and
now
you know i actually believe that
everything worked out how it was
supposed to you know i don't still want
to be an actor even when i work with my
actor clients i have no desire i'm not
longingly looking at their careers i was
supposed to be a graphic designer that's
that became my true love
um
but the lesson that i learned there that
i i wanted to i feel like
was one of the reasons i wanted to
become a coach
is because i think there are so many
artists that have those moments where
they're maybe told they're not good
enough or they think it themselves
and i said in the book
that i wish the teacher saw in me
although i really need to take full
responsibility and say i wish i saw it
in myself
but i i think i wish the teacher saw in
me that i had all these other qualities
that could potentially lead to success
in a career like hollywood right i was
already showing leadership skills right
i was secretary of the drama club i was
i was president over 250 person chorus
have you know worked my way up there and
so i
i already had so i was like a
self-starter you know like i had a
positive outlook i was determined and
ambitious like i had so many qualities
that could help me succeed even if i
wasn't the absolute star
you know and even if i didn't maybe get
into one of the top desired theater
programs like there's theater programs
and countries all yeah earn schools all
around the country
um
i don't know i just think that you know
i i own that for myself now
that i wish i saw it in myself but i
don't think at that moment i understood
that so much more than talent was
required to succeed and now looking at
like the people who did you know pursue
theater
in college from that program in high
school i had only one or two of them is
actually doing it
so
um and i was still able to create you
know pretty great career for myself in
hollywood and break in when i didn't
know anybody
and i and i didn't do that because i was
this phenomenal designer i did it
because i had all these other qualities
that helped me break in
and we don't know someone's motives
behind why they say something too or
don't say something yeah totally i mean
you know and it could have been her own
it doesn't really matter i i think but
you know
it was just it was just a moment for me
that i just want to help people not feel
that way because i feel like if there's
a dream in your heart
you can pursue it you know jack canfield
has this quote that i always say
where he says you wouldn't be given a
dream unless you had the capacity to
fulfill it
and i really believe that i really
believe that you wouldn't be given a
dream unless you had the capacity to
fill it doesn't mean right in this
moment when you're 17 years old that you
have all the tools and are able to
fulfill it now
right but
but it creates potential like it says
that the potential is a hundred percent
there
is it better to try to avoid making
money as an artist like should someone
not set out to do their art and also try
to make money at it right away
i believe
that both can happen and so i go into it
believing
this dream will provide for me because i
have this desire of course it's going to
financially support me as well you know
it might take time to get to where you
want to be but
i have this whole chapter
i know i keep dropping my book and like
name dropping my book but i do have this
whole chapter about you know this idea
of being a starving artist because i
think that those two words you rarely
hear them without each other and
i believe that you don't have to be a
starving artist and i also believe that
there's nothing wrong with desiring
financial success or with you know with
wanting to make money from your art so
to me it's about i believe that i can
create art that is going to financially
support me
and really having that belief from the
beginning
most artists don't make money especially
right up front wouldn't it be easier to
accept that most artists
accepting that belief
equals determining your fate
right so your fate is a hundred percent
dependent upon your belief so if you
believe that most artists don't make
money in the beginning that a hundred
percent will be your fate
and what you do when you accept that
belief when you take that belief on you
are now putting yourself into the most
people pool sure most people don't make
a ton of money in the beginning
do you have to be most people
right and so
can you find an example like i always
love to talk about the example of
gilmore girls this is one of my favorite
shows but alexis bledel had no acting
credits on her resume before booking
that title lead role
so
you know i mean she was modeling before
she had a model in korea there but but
you know breaking into hollywood as an
actress
and then you know i i don't know what
the going rates were back then but
series regulars now start at like 25 30
000 an episode depending on the network
right and so you so she technically went
from zero to
seven you know several thousand dollars
per week per episode and back then they
were doing 22 24 episode seasons
so there's always going to be an
exception to the rule
and i think it's better to focus on the
exception than to focus on the rule i
think it's better to go into it with
well i could be that exception
because when you when you accept the
rule and you say oh i'm going to be like
most people then that's exactly what
your experience will be
is there a danger in not thinking that
you're part of that pool
is are you saying like is there a danger
to think of yourself in this smaller
high achievers pool yeah oh it's okay i
mean what danger i i think it's like i
guess the danger could be like oh but
then you're like putting yourself in
this pool where people make it and what
if you don't
i think that um
there's no danger in beli believing that
your dreams are possible
in a and this is like the high achiever
right like in a really big way in in a
more committed way than most people
i i don't think there's any danger in
that and i think that like
the well what if it doesn't happen
i again believe my success is inevitable
so to me there's no specific time frame
that it has to happen and i just know
it's going to happen i don't know when i
don't know how i don't know where but
it's going to happen
and i have that belief throughout so
there's no
well if it doesn't happen by x that
means you're you're in the most people
pool you know i just don't think that
way
do you think other people
paying you to do your art inherently
makes it worse because you don't have
the same level of freedom to create the
art that's in your heart what if i
believed that the work is in my that the
work that is in my heart is what people
will ask for
right so i think it's it's changing the
belief right it's changing the belief
about it like oh
i'm gonna have to do something that's
not really in my heart that i don't
really want to do because the clients
ask me or whatever right sure that
happens and that has happened on my path
you know like i had day job graphic
design jobs that i did not enjoy but i
but they financially supported me so i
could stay in la and keep doing this so
you know i've had that experience but i
think in the bigger picture
um
if i'm doing work that doesn't feel good
i stop doing it or i don't like like
there is
you know i'll be honest i didn't love
working on cop shows because from a
graphic standpoint it's really boring
you know it's like you're designing
signs for hospitals and
prisons like like this is basically the
only graphics i do and the rectangles
with text and that's it you know it's
not a very creative
um
you know genre in terms of graphics and
so i did a cop show i did not enjoy it
and then i was like okay i'm not gonna
do this again and then i would turn down
cop shows in the future right so so for
me it's more about like what if i just
believe that the work i want to do is
what will be asked of me
can you give us an example of that
happening was there an example where you
saw a show that you wanted to do and you
said that's the kind of art i want to do
though that's the color scheme i like
that how do i make that my reality yeah
i mean
it wasn't that specific in terms of like
color schemes or certain art it was more
just like i would love to do something
that's more creative where maybe every
week the graphics are different you know
where i get to explore more with like
different signage or different props or
you know things that are integral to the
story that are just inherently more
interesting and um you know shortly
after that i did book a tv show called
chasing life which was the abc family
show that i said i loved which was a
great experience and i got to do really
cool fun different graphics you know um
i feel like my portfolio really expanded
from that show because we got to do
um you know so many different things
like we did a marathon once and i got to
do these like marathon banner graphics
but then also you know the runners tags
that they had to wear and and then i got
to do wardrobe you know like there was a
camp and i got to design the sweatshirts
that the counselors were like there was
really just variety
um and that was fun for me more so than
you know the cop graphics kind of stuff
where you're just designing rectangles
with text so um yeah and then that that
became really fun and i said okay so
this is going to be my new standard
i want to work on a show that feels fun
and creative
um
and and you know those are the only
things i would say yes to now unless it
was blade runner then that would be cool
no i i turned down sons of anarchy oh
you did oh wow no no i i don't care how
big the show is if it's something i know
that i don't think i will enjoy
um i won't do it my happiness is is now
more important so so the so the let the
colored leathers on the back of the
motorcycle jackets that just didn't hit
yeah like okay that's like that'd be
cool but my point was that like there
you know
right it wasn't even even if it's
something even if a project is like big
and well known if i don't think that i
will enjoy doing it then i will still
turn it down sure sure
that makes sense
and i just want to add something there
because some people might be going oh
well you have the luxury of turning it
down because you're at a certain point
in your career now where you can say no
and you know things are going to come in
but i just want to add on to that is
that when i turn down something that
doesn't feel like a good fit for me i am
making room
for something better to come in
right so as long as you say yes to
things you don't want to do you now
don't even have room for something new
to come in so
you know it's not even necessarily about
i'm at a certain place in my career
where now i can say
no to things to me it's really about
what do i want to make room for in my
life even if you know the great example
is i talk about
all the time
people that stay non-union you know
especially actors you know when they're
afraid to join sag because once they
join sag
they can no longer do non-union work and
that is scary to them because
they only know non-union work and they
feel that non-union is easier to book
than sag work right and so they like to
stay non-union and i say
when you are staying non-union as long
as you can you are staying where you are
as long as you can
even though it might take a little
longer for the sag stuff to start
flowing in and it might be a little
scarier that doesn't mean that it won't
flow in and as long as you're choosing
the other thing it'll never flow in
right so it doesn't really matter how
far you are in your career to be able to
turn things down or to you know to be
able to start making room for what it is
you truly desire it might take some time
to bring it in but you want to at least
open yourself up and make room for the
things that you really want
that's a good example right there yeah i
know a lot of people they pay off they
don't want to pay the dues and they keep
the eligibility status but then they
just keep
keep working yeah good example
what do you teach your clients about
money
oh man
what don't i teach about no uh money is
such
an important topic i think
on and really anyone's journey not even
specific to hollywood
i am still
in my own
learning journey you know of
wealth consciousness and working on my
money mindset
but what i like to teach them is
really focus on what is possible
and
what sounds exciting instead of focusing
on what doesn't feel good so for example
this
this uh
example comes up a lot because i
remember my clients telling me about
this
other teacher teaching about this
when you
are focusing on
if you're a writer director actor and
you're focusing on
this is how much of my paycheck goes to
taxes and this is how much of my
paycheck goes to my agent or manager and
i am left with so little
when you are focusing on i am left with
so little
you are going to create more of that
in your life in your career right
whatever we focus on expands so instead
of going oh my gosh if i book a co-star
and i only make 800 for the day and then
i guess i start with the thousands
easier math to do in my head you know i
only make a thousand dollars for the day
and you know uh 30 of that is going to
taxes 20 is going to my agent a manager
and i'm only going home with like 500
bucks that really sucks
to me that is the most people thinking
right so in terms of money instead of
focusing on
how much it sucks when you're left with
little money at the end of the day
instead what if you focus on
what if i booked a recurring
role for twenty thousand dollars and
then even though some of it's going to
taxes and my agent and manager i'm still
left with a pretty nice chunk of change
right so instead of focusing on
limitations and what
you know feels like your fate is gonna
be and really focus on um
you know the the downside of all of that
focus on
what's possible
focus on being the one that gets 10
million dollar paychecks from a movie
you know again it's like the most people
pool and the high achiever pool that
high achiever pool people who are making
10 million dollars a movie might be
smaller than most people in the industry
but let's focus on that because that's
how you get there
you know so it's so important to really
think from an abundant mindset about
what is possible
how do you teach people to stretch that
i guess it's a muscle
i get kind of like what i was telling
you with you know my success is
inevitable
in addition to suggesting lots of books
and resources that i love that i think
are really helpful um because i think
that it's
a money mindset is a
deep conversation that needs to happen
over time we need to unlearn a lot of
things and relearn new things and take a
look at our own
money patterns but
just like with my success inevitable
it's like let's start looking for proof
okay
i had a client
that booked a 17 000
job
right so there's proof
that
somebody i worked with you know in the
recent you know past or whatever
um
booked a bigger paycheck was able to
receive a bigger paycheck so now your
subconscious goes oh
so it's possible oh so it's possible for
me to get that right so again it's like
feeding your subconscious mind proof
of what's possible because proof exists
we just choose not to focus on it we
choose to focus on the people that are
coming home with 500 and feeling broke
but instead
all this other evidence also exists
we're just saying that it's so rare and
that that's not possible for us or it's
like winning the lottery right
and so
it's really about looking for that proof
and going okay that is what i want to
focus on and that is what i'm working
towards
the gilmore girls example that you gave
again she had been modeling but she'd
never had a speaking role no
wow
and how long was i i mean that show is
doesn't it like seven seasons and then
they recently did the
you know netflix special that was four
episodes long
yeah but there's great like you know i i
love the show so i've watched interviews
and things like that behind the scenes
and i read lauren graham's one of her
books
and lauren graham talks about how she
played
uh alexis blidell's mother as the two of
them for people that don't know gilmore
girls lauren graham talks about she's
like if you ever see a scene where i'm
like grabbing alexis arm and pulling her
close to me she's like i was pulling her
on her mark
because she was so new that she you know
she didn't in the beginning you know she
didn't necessarily know all those things
like oh you need to stand on your mark
and you know things that a seasoned
actor would know and so even without all
that that's how new she was even without
all that knowledge and all that
experience she's still booked the title
one of the title roles series regular
like seven seasons wow
see and that's possible
when we focus on that instead of you
know
the actor who books one co-star a year
and really struggles right it's like
both evidence exists
which one do we want to focus on
how does money change an artist
i don't think money changes anybody
i think
again it's it's all internal so
whatever it looks like money changed
was already there inside
right so sometimes they say you know
fame is like
holding up a magnifying glass to what's
already there
you know like for example i worked on a
show i won't mention names but i worked
on a show where one of the lead
actresses was not a very nice person
and
i
found out that people who knew her
before she was famous said that she was
like that then you know she wasn't a
nice person that it's like it's like
holding up a magnifying glass so i don't
think that money i don't think any
external thing changes us you know i
think that only you know i mean events
and things like that i guess can shift
our perception or our feelings our
beliefs but i don't think like a
tangible thing like money which is just
like a value exchange i don't think that
necessarily changes people i think again
it's like a magnifying glass to what's
already there
so
a lot of times people will feel when i
have x amount of money
all my money problems will go away
but
having more money doesn't change your
spending habits it doesn't change your
saving habits or what you do with your
money how you treat your money you are
the person that does that it might
inspire you to change your habits you
know it might inspire you to do things
differently but i don't think money
actually changes people
from the people you've worked with
how does their outward success change
the people around them oh good question
i
cuz i love that like to me that it makes
me so happy to help i say spread the
light like i want to spread the light in
hollywood you know the people that i
work with helping them feel good and
feel inspired again will then help
people around them feel inspired so
again i think it's more about the
internal changes than the external
things that they book the projects that
they book
um i think that you know like um one of
my clients was saying that her mom said
oh you know you're you're so upbeat
recently you know you're so positive and
happy and she was like yes you know i'm
a month working with erica um so i think
that it's more the internal shift
that impacts people around them
in a positive way but you know i guess
the things that they the projects that
they might book or the external things
um
can kind of
i guess with the internal shifts also
help impact people but
you know what i'm seeing and what i and
what i really hope is that it impacts
people for the better where it inspires
other people to go after their dreams
and it shows other people what's
possible
you know
when i
first started out 13 almost 13 years ago
i read jack camfield's success
principles it's my very first self-help
book i ever read and i was like this is
the greatest thing ever
i loved it so much and i think it really
helped me break in
to hollywood so quickly and one of the
tactics that he talked about was writing
your goals on an index card
and so i would do that for every goal
for years i don't do it anymore
um because my my belief around that has
shifted a little bit but like my dad
started writing his goals down on index
cards i was like that is so cool you
know i think
you know there's something so incredible
about inspiring others to go after their
dreams or to believe in more you know
believe in more possibility for
themselves by seeing
people they know or love do it
but what if that doesn't happen
what if it doesn't inspire others what
if it takes another turn
what do you mean
what if somehow
they can't handle that
have you seen that in like the person
who who's succeeding or the person
that's watching them
the person that's succeeding what if
some of the individuals around them
that threatens them have you worked with
your clients on that and and how do they
internalize that so they're feeling
threatened by their success
or the dynamics changed power structures
change
and so it it upsets the apple cart yeah
i mean that absolutely does happen and
i've coached many clients through that i
think especially with friends
um and i think that
you know
you can't control somebody else's
journey
right so so like my client can't control
their friend
getting on board and being excited and
being inspired or feeling threatened or
feeling you know not good about it or
whatever right
we can't control somebody else's journey
they're on their own path and so it's
not up to us how they feel
and and one of the things that i work
with my clients a lot is because a lot
of times when we're doing the mindset
it's really the internal shifts that
that impact their relationships the most
and and a lot of times
i say that when you start changing and
growing what you used to tolerate
becomes less tolerable
so
the people that maybe aren't getting on
board
maybe were never meant to get on board
with them right and maybe it was
something they were tolerating before
but
it's like they can't even tolerate
anymore they don't want to be around
them right so i think that you know it's
important that we surround ourselves
with people who support us and who want
us to win and are you know and excited
for us and if people are feeling you
know negative nancy's they're feeling
down
um that's okay you know they're on their
own path
but the more we
surround ourselves with people like that
the more time we spend with them the
more it can start to
drag us down if we're not incredibly
strong about our own energy and thought
process
so i never think it's about like oh you
need to break up with this friend you
know i don't think it's necessarily
about cutting people out of your life
but just being more
um present and and aware
of the kinds of conversations you have
with them and and the things that they
say and then how it impacts how you feel
when you've had a client reach
tremendous success what were some of the
surprises that they weren't ready to
handle
well
i work with i've worked with a lot of
new people so tremendous success i i
don't know if
you know that's that's all relative and
i don't know if i've like i don't know
if i've ever coached somebody that that
achieved something
so incredible that they weren't ready
for because i think that the work that
we do
gets them ready for it
um
and that's always what it's about like
it's all again it's always the internal
thing you know how do you feel about
what is happening and do you have
support around you
you know that's like why some of my
clients end up staying into like i have
a membership where it's just a couple
coaching calls a month in a group
setting so that they can keep up with
the
you know the work to keep up with that
belief system keep up with that mindset
work so that as they do achieve things
they have the support system to to help
them you know handle
anything that comes their way
so so some of this has never come as a
surprise to them it's they've taken
these steps and they were ready
emotionally yeah nothing's ever a
surprise i mean like
because i train them to expect success
and i don't even i shouldn't even say i
train them i don't want to take
responsibility they they shift their
belief system to believe that their
success is coming so
nothing it's never a surprise it's
exciting and they're really happy about
it and you know it's funny like even
small things one of my clients
um texted me the other day in our in her
session
she she moved home during the pandemic
and is going to move back to l.a soon
and she was like you know when do i move
like i'm looking at places i don't know
when the timing is right and i said when
you find a place that you love that
feels really good and i was like watch i
bet this week you'll find a place now
that we have this conversation and she
texted me the next day and was like
you won't believe one of those
apartments just became available that i
was interested in
so there's never it's never a surprise
it's expected i mean it's
it's surprised in the way of like wow
this really did come true this really
did happen and there's excitement around
that but
never a surprise
so expect success
okay i like that and do you think with
the every
people pool
it's not expected correct i'm hoping
yeah correct i'm fingers crossed okay
ask anyone ask ask most people you know
ask them
what they believe about about their
success and or about the next booking or
the next job or whatever and
yeah most people do not expect it
they expect failure or they expect it to
take a long time or they expect struggle
erica would you mind reading a page or
two from your book i just so happen to
have it on my lap right okay
i would be happy to like i'm like a
teacher this is chapter
it's called own your power
okay
your dream comes from the most powerful
place
you
it's born from divine inspiration one of
the most powerful forces in the universe
this calling becomes a burning desire
one that gives you ambition perseverance
drive and even compassion in a way
you've never felt before
it helps form the most powerful version
of you there ever was
and yet the moment it becomes an
impossible feat you have to achieve
the power is immediately stripped away
it's your superpower and kryptonite all
in one
but the stripping of your power is
really an illusion
it's a choice to give it away and a
choice you don't have to make
instead of feeling at the mercy of
others to make your dream come true
you can take your power back by
realizing as abraham hicks says
they are all just pawns in the law of
attraction game
you get to control so much more than you
think
you get to control your energy
your vibration your beliefs your
strategy
your actions your risks and asks
and the most important of them all
you get to create your reality
all of those things combined with the
belief in abundance and limitless
opportunities leads to a world where it
doesn't matter if someone says yes or no
to you
the dream is happening no matter what
i think one of my superpowers is
reminding people how powerful they
really are that shift in energy can be
all it takes to manifest exciting new
opportunities
because how you show up to the world is
how the world will show up for you
whatever you believe will be reflected
back to you
if you feel powerless in your dream
pursuit you will have experiences that
confirm those feelings
and vice versa
ps
owning your power is so much more fun so
let's choose that shall we
let me help you by busting the power
myths that your subconscious is fighting
for
here is one of the power myths
gatekeepers
gatekeepers are like the bouncers of the
club deciding who gets in
it feels like they have all the power
and artists are at the mercy of their
decision
actors are at the mercy of casting
directors
authors are at the mercy of publishers
startups are at the mercy of investors
it feels like these gatekeepers are in
charge of our fate and we have no
control over what they say
access to our dreams is in their hands
so how are we supposed to feel powerful
in those moments
we hold none of the power in those
decisions
clap
that's me waking you up from the
hypnotic spell you're under
time for the powerful truth
powerful truth
these gatekeepers do not determine your
fate
only you can do that pillar number seven
says that your success is inevitable
which means your fate has already been
decided
any single gatekeeper or any single
opportunity will not break your chances
of succeeding
it's already been decided
your success is a done deal
who cares what the gatekeeper says your
person is coming
your opportunity is coming
because it's inevitable
and if that's the case
what if these gatekeepers were in fact
allies
what if they were friends
what if they were your support system
your cheer squad
what if the universe always placed
people on your path to help you
and what if that help didn't always come
in the pretty package you want a no
could be just as much a gift as a yes
when jack canfield's book was turned
down
144 times by publishers
what if that was all a gift because the
publisher he was meant to work with
happened to be the 145th
what if it's all working out perfectly
we tend to put gatekeepers on pedestals
because we think they hold the power
but you hold the power
take them down from that pedestal they
are just people
they are pawns in your game
and this game is in the highest good of
everyone
you know the value you bring
you know you were meant to do this so it
can't not work out
if this gatekeeper doesn't let you in it
says nothing about your potential
it says nothing about your future or
your ability to succeed
it just wasn't a match
but i promise you
your people are out there keep going
because they're looking for you too
excellent
that's just two pages
why did you choose that passage
well one because
i think that it's something a lot of
people struggle with
i think that
so many filmmakers feel powerless in
this industry and they are constantly
searching for ways to feel
powerful that's why a lot of people do
their own work you know film their own
projects because they want to feel in
control and they feel like everything's
out of control so
i wanted to read that
to address that you know exact thing i
think that there's so many ways that we
can feel
you know be in our own power without it
even having to be something as literal
as filming your own content
um
and also because so many people have
read the beginning of the book the first
chapter and i think a lot of what we
talked about today was stories from the
first couple chapters and so i wanted to
share something from the back of the
book the third section
um
that to me feels like
this is how a high achiever thinks you
know a high achiever doesn't feel at the
mercy of gatekeepers they feel that they
have the power to create whatever they
want and if something doesn't work out
or doesn't happen the way they wanted it
to that's okay it doesn't mean that
it it's not still going to happen
and how did you feel writing that
chapter
did it did were you sort of empowered
i mean as you're writing it
were you almost transformed into another
world yeah i mean everything i wrote i
need to hear over and over again you
know i read my own book a lot
and i'm not trying to say that in like a
super arrogant way but in a way of like
i needed to hear this again today you
know
um yeah i really feel like i
i mean so much of the book came from
working with my clients and the work
that we've done over several years now
um
but
i do feel like i sort of
i don't want to say channeled you know
but i just feel like it it came from a
place like i i felt like this was
this idea to write this book was
divinely sent to me like i just i just
got the idea it wasn't something i
strategize i didn't strategize and say
oh i should write a book i was like i
just felt
this feeling of like you ha like you
have to get this message
out to help people
you know and then when covent hit not to
be super morbid i was like
i have to get this message out before i
die what if i get coveted and die like i
was really feeling like i need to finish
this book i told my mom where like my
book files were on my computer
i was just a little fearful during you
know like during this pandemic um
but
yeah i just i don't know i just i really
want
more people to
to hear this message and hopefully it
will help transform you know their
careers
when you tell your clients this message
are they resistant at first
oh yeah i mean yes and no and and myself
as well you know
i i share this story with my clients a
lot when i was
first starting out you know
really embracing some of this for myself
i was working with a life coach
and
we were talking about money abundance in
terms of money
and
i was really struggling financially that
month and i said i'm so broke
i'm so broke i really need a haircut i
can't afford a haircut i can't afford
anything
she said erica
you are an abundant person you are so
abundant you have access to money all
around you
and i said do you want to look at my
bank account i have hardly any money in
it
and i went back and forth with her
arguing
about how broke i was no you don't
understand you need to hear me i am
broke i am struggling
i need to be heard
and
my poor coach she was so patient and
kind with me you know because i had so
much resistance and now of course
looking back i share that story because
when i look back now i can see like i
was really fighting for my limitations
i was fighting to stay where i was i
wasn't listening to her when she was you
know like it's like if i listen to her
like i there i could have been open to
solutions like with the fedex logo right
there could have been solutions in front
of me that i didn't see because i didn't
want to see them i wanted to instead
prove
how broke i was
so i myself have been resistant and
i've definitely had clients be resistant
especially in terms of not not really
necessarily
the belief but
the action that it should then lead to
so for example like one time i worked
with a client who i was like you need to
change your day job
because her day job had her traveling a
lot
and she
would travel for
like at least one week every month so
she was out of town a lot and i was like
you want to audition and this is pretty
pandemic you know nothing with
self-doubt you want to audition and you
know get representation and audition and
books work you're not even here to do it
this day job i understand that it's
supporting you but you need a different
day job that's going to support
what you're actually trying to do
because right now it's blocking you
and
it took her
i think like six weeks i mean it took
her weeks
you know because that's a scary thing
you know that's definitely a risk but
you know working through the mindset of
it of like believing that your success
is inevitable if you take this risk
a you you start to believe of course
there's another day job out there for me
of course i can believe that that's
possible that i can be financially
supported in a day job that also gives
me time to audition you know and stay in
la at least and not be traveling right
it's like you have to
start to believe
that things can work out for you even
with these little things of i have to
believe not only that my success is
inevitable but that i can find a
different day job i have to believe that
i can be financially supported you know
yeah so we worked through
you know shifting her beliefs and
eventually she came around changed her
day job got an agent right away
booked her first co-star booked a lead
in a tv movie you know so so things
really shifted for her but you know it's
okay to have resist it's okay that it
takes time i think as long as you're
open to doing the work it doesn't have
to happen overnight
but if you're if you're open to doing
that work i think
then that's that's where the benefit
will be
when you had the down period after you
had moved out here got this great job
and then the recession hit or was
already in motion
and i believe then the show was canceled
were you fighting for your limitations
oh yeah
oh yes
um
yes i really was and again it goes back
to you know i had those like blinders on
of only seeing the problem
and not allowing myself to open up to
solutions
i didn't do nothing like i you know i'm
an ambitious person and i i tried you
know i put myself out there i think i
cold emailed a bunch of you i i try to
get another job so it's not like i
didn't do anything
but
i
had those blinders on and i was
definitely
like you know it's like
if my mom suggested like oh you should
you could go for a drive or go down to
the ocean no mom i can't do that that
means i have to put gas in the car and i
can't afford gas you know so
it was like i was constantly focused on
the problem
um
and fighting to stay there essentially
you know my mom was like trying to tell
me all these things that could
potentially help me
and it took me a long time to get to a
place where i stopped fighting for my
limitations and i finally opened myself
up to help
at what point in your career did you go
without work for was it a year
okay
what happened yeah that was in 2009
and
that
contact that one connection that i had
made helped me get that first show
but i didn't have like
a huge rolodex of people that i knew in
the industry so
it was really challenging to book
another job because you know as from a
graphic designer
standpoint you really need to know
people you know one once you get into
the union there is an availability list
that you can put yourself on and you can
get some jobs from your name being on
the availability list but people are
only going to that list until they've
you know
they've gone through they've exhausted
their list of people they know
so it's so much about who you know and i
just didn't know enough people yet you
know my pool was so small
so
um i
i had you know it was like the worst
year of my life because it was also the
recession and so i couldn't even get a
waitressing job
like i remember this one day
where i saw craigslist posting for a
waitress interview a server interview
and i got my car right away and drove
right over and there were already like
10 people in line and they were only
taking one person
so
it that was really challenging too and
like i really you know even now i try to
get better but i tend to tie myself
worth to how much money i have
and so
when i like couldn't even make a living
as like getting a server job or
something like that or any kind of side
job
um
it and and this was also before uber and
lyft existed you know i couldn't drive
for instacart i couldn't i couldn't do
those things it couldn't be a postmates
person
um and so
that was really hard for me too so not
only like struggling to find the work
but then tie my worth
to that and and feeling
so unworthy of success or anything that
i wanted
that was really hard
how well do you remember the depression
that you faced oh gosh
i very well because i still experience
it all the time like i think i'm prone
to depression i call it situational
depression because it usually comes from
a situation so something happens
um to cause me to be depressed i don't
normally feel it just
to feel it with no trigger
um so i recall it very well because i
felt it again many times
since then
um but it was just a really pivotal time
in my life like i remember it so well
so well
i can really connect
you know to those feelings and
you know
what i tried to do you know just all the
things that i did and
even though it was almost 13 years ago
at this point 12 years ago i i still
remember it very clearly
that was a really rough time for a lot
of people yes it was and i mean thank
god i didn't have kids or didn't have a
home you know so many people lost their
homes and you know much worse than you
know fortunately i was able to
stay afloat and i you know i had two
roommates at the time and so i was able
to still stay in la which is amazing it
could have been much worse but yeah it
was a tough time
how are you able to book a job at the
end of all that i asked for
help it was so hard
i my cousin told me a story
um
it's a short story i can tell it quickly
and people probably heard it before
i forget all the details but essentially
there was a man in his house and it
started raining
and as the rain came down it didn't stop
and it started to flood
and he was like oh my gosh
how am i gonna be okay and he just kept
praying to god
god save me i will be okay please help
me god
and
the flood kept growing and the rain was
getting worse and so he goes to the
upstairs in his house so he can get to
the next level because it's starting to
come into his house and
he sees
um someone in their truck
drives by
and they're like hey man we can help you
come jump in the truck and he was like
no god will save me i'm going to go
upstairs to this upper level i will be
fine
and then the rain
keeps coming and the flood is rising
and someone in a boat passes by
and they're like hey jump in the boat
we'll help you we'll save you they see
him in this window you know jump out of
your win
and he's like no i'll be okay i'm
praying god will save me
and then finally it becomes like
unbearable and he has to literally climb
to the roof of his house
and a helicopter comes and flies over
and drops a ladder and says you know we
grab the ladder we can save you
i said no god will save me i prayed and
i know god will save me
and the water rose so much
that he couldn't go anywhere and he
ended up drowning
and died
and he goes to heaven and he's like god
what the heck i prayed for you to save
me why didn't you save me
and god said i sent you a truck i sent
you a boat i sent you a helicopter
and when my cousin told me that story
it really helped me
see that like if you're drowning it's
okay to ask for help you know i felt
very ashamed
of where i was
you know in my life and how much i was
struggling because again i really tied
it to my self-worth and i just thought
you know i'm not a good enough human
being i don't deserve this and so i
don't even deserve somebody's help you
know
and
i would ghost people's texts you know i
just wouldn't even respond to friends
texts or calls because i was so ashamed
i was so embarrassed you know if they
say how are you what's going on and i
would say nothing nine months later and
still nothing is going on i was so
ashamed
so
after my cousin told me that story
i was like okay
and so i reached out to one of the girls
that i had become friendly with from the
first show
and i told her look
i really need a job if you know of
anyone looking because she was the same
age as me but she had already been in
the industry longer and she knew a lot
of people and so she had found other
work i said i really need a job if you
hear of anything could you let me know
and she heard of something
and she recommended me and it was glee
and
they called me
and they called me a week after i
finally got a waitressing job
a week after and i was like
you have no idea how much i want to come
work for you but it was to fill in for
somebody for just a couple days
and i was like
you have no idea how badly i want to say
yes to you but i just spent like eight
or nine months with no job and i just
got this waitressing job a week ago i
don't think i can quit this for just a
couple days work even though i really
want to
and so i said like if something else
comes up longer term please please call
me
and a month later they did
and they called me and they said now we
need someone to fill in for the rest of
the season
and i gave my notice
after a month of waitressing and i went
and worked on glee
wow because that goes back to that
energy shift and so here you had
something you finally got
a waitressing job after you know racing
down to an open call for one and then
then this other one opened up so that
goes back to what you're talking about
earlier definitely i mean even just
getting the waitressing job it filled me
up so much you know and not even just
self-worth and feeling like wow okay i
finally have some money coming in i can
survive and i have a job
but also being around other people you
know because i was so afraid to spend
money that i wouldn't leave my room
i would stay in my room in my apartment
like all day every day i was afraid to
leave
because it would cost me money to leave
and i just i wasn't around people and so
that i think also helped to be around
people and you know waitressing your
your hustling and walking fast and
suddenly so i was getting exercise again
and moving my body you know all of these
things that were
beneficial that i think really shifted
my energy than to be open for
a tv show
very interesting
wow what a story
so so when you got the waitressing job
how did that feel because i realized
that wasn't your ultimate destination no
it wasn't but i was elated you know i
just needed something i hadn't had any
work in so long i i was so
so happy and so grateful to get that
weight choosing job yes
wow
do you ever go back to that restaurant
well then know now you probably can't
because
it's just takeout if it's still around
right well so that so it's funny because
so it's it's on the block near where i
live so i could walk there and i
felt so guilty about
like leaving after just a month and i
could tell the manager was not happy
with me
that on glee i was an assistant and i
was in charge of getting lunch every day
so i would always say hey we should go
to this restaurant and so i gave them
business and we would order from the
whole office and order lunch there and i
would go there and pick it up because i
wanted to still give them business you
know because i felt so bad about leaving
um and so and i and that restaurant was
amazing food so good but it doesn't
exist anymore and another restaurant is
in its place now that's also a very good
restaurant and i go there when it's open
yes
that's a great story and and and even
the staff like the people in the kitchen
and the other servers like some of them
i still talk to you to this day some of
them went to the restaurant next door
and i always say hi i get so excited to
see them and
it's nice
do you believe in visualization yes
how does it work
well
it works however you want it to work but
i think that
so i'm really fascinated by the science
behind it
i just think it's so fascinating and so
dr joe dispenza teaches a lot of the
science behind it i'm so fascinated so
he talks about
he gave this really good example of a an
experiment that they did
i don't know if he conducted or someone
else did a long time ago
where they monitored the brain
of somebody rehearsing practicing the
piano
and it was for a certain amount of hours
a couple days a week or something and
they
literally would get brain scans or you
know i don't know the scientific term
but they studied their brain
um to see what happens like what part of
the brain lights up you know what
happens in your brain when you're
rehearsing playing the piano
and then they did the same thing
but asked him to just rehearse it in his
mind
just visualize yourself rehearsing for
the same amount of time so if it was
three hours spend three hours rehearsing
playing the piano not actually touching
a piano and what they found was the
exact same part of the brain lit up
and what this was really showing them is
that your brain doesn't really know the
difference between something imagined or
visualized and something real that's
right in front of you
and they talk about when you
visualize what you want happening and
you you close your eyes and you really
see it
in detail
and you play it out like a movie in your
mind
you're actually impacting the quantum
field i mean this is like quantum
physics and it's getting a little
sciency but you're actually like
impacting the quantum field around you
and it creates possibility like it
create like now now that you envisioned
it it exists in real life somewhere
and he talks about
he does a much better job explaining
because i'm an art brain not a science
brain and so i kind of summarized the
science that he shared but the way that
i remember it but he said that you know
for example in the morning when you wake
up
if you have a thought i have to go to
the bathroom right when you wake up and
then your body goes to the bathroom so
your body physically follows the thought
so when you visualize you know play out
this movie in your mind of you booking a
project or you know
getting anything that you want
your body then will follow the thought
and it will lead you to actions and
things to do and
you know connections people to talk to
whatever
um
to to follow that thought because your
brain thinks it's real doesn't know the
difference
and and joe talks about dr joe talks
about um and i don't really do this
enough i'm a very visual person so it's
super easy for me to visualize and i i
can kind of do it without even having to
go into a deep meditation like i can
just i can connect to it so easily
because i'm such a visual person but
dr joe talks about like for this to work
really well
it's best if you can do this in a
meditative state so if you can just
close your eyes
and
visualize whatever it is that you want
to visualize let's say like i do this
great meditation visualization my
clients were like i might walk them
through a day of them going to set
you know booking you know on a project
that they love you know they get up and
they get in their car and we play out
the whole day you drive to paramount
studios you get to your trailer you sit
in the hair and make you know literally
all the details of it and like what's
around you and um dr joe talks about
like incorporating your five senses
you know you know sense of like how does
it smell you know what what are you
touching what do you so to really um
you know make it come to life in your
mind
and so he says that if you can get to a
place in your meditative state
and every time i talk about this i'm
like erica you need to do this more
because this is so great if you can get
to a place in your meditative state
where you're visualizing and you forget
about you're no longer connected to time
your body or your environment
meaning you're just so into this
visualization that you have no idea five
minutes past or 30 minutes past right so
you're not like super aware of time
you are not fidgeting you know or
touching your body so like you're
just so into it that you're not even
aware of your body or itchy or you know
whatever we do when we're
wiggling in a in a meditation and then
your environment like you're not
thinking about the room that you're
sitting in
when you can get to a place where you're
not no longer aware of those three
things
that's like the magic space where the
visualization comes to life and really
kind of creates in this quantum field
so
i think visualization is just such an
amazing tool for us to use like one it
just gets you excited you know i think
it's just good to help get you in the
energy
which i can even do just talking about
the specifics of my dream i get excited
you know
if anyone asks me about like the house i
want to buy i will go on forever and i
get so excited and i can tell you all
the details that's like brings me that
energy of the visualization
um but so i think it's good for that
sense and like it gets you excited and
it gets you connected to the possibility
which then will lead to ideas or actions
or bigger risks you know
any of the thing that good energy will
lead to
um and then also you're from a
scientific perspective you know you're
essentially creating this possibility in
the quantum field
and now you're
expecting it to happen and so you're
doing all the things you would do
if you knew it was coming
do you have any examples of how this
creative visualization has helped
some of your clients
so
one of the things that i have my clients
do in addition to visualizing is to
write it out
and so
i have what they do we call it a clear
intentions list and so they write like a
list of what their intentions are what
they want to create and so
i mean this happens all the time they
get the agent or manager that matches
everything on their list you know they
create things all the time and one of my
clients actually
the other day had posted in the facebook
group that
she recently got a new agent
that
feels really great it's a great
relationship they're bringing her
high quality auditions they they
understand each other it seems like they
really support her dream you know like
all these dreamy things that people want
from a rep that they often don't get
and she
said i i because i told her i'm like man
i wish we could go back to your two-year
ago self and tell that version of you
like that you got this great rep and
you're having this wonderful experience
and she's like i know
she said like i
remember one of your other clients
having it happen to her a year ago
and
feeling like so excited for her and
seeing that it was possible and really
wanting that for myself
and and then it happened for her so um
so not so it's not necessarily that
they're going through the whole like
meditation visualization although i
think a lot of my clients are doing that
naturally
um
but really visualizing in any kind of
sense
even outside of meditation what it is
they want and then having it happen
do you ever see people who are unable to
make positive changes in their life
yeah
i do i think
you know no judgment again i think
everyone's on their own path
and actually this is something that i
had to work on as a coach to not
take that on for myself and beat myself
up about it like i didn't do a good
enough job i didn't i you know i
couldn't
i couldn't change them i you know my
work couldn't
um
help them change
you know i've struggled with that in the
past
um and really had to learn like i give
them the tools but it's up to them what
they do with it you know i can't make
anybody do anything
so
um
i've definitely seen that happen but i
do think that everyone's on their own
path and i think that people come around
when they
when they come around and when they when
they need to when it's right for them
um
you know tony robbins talks about how
everyone moves towards pain or pleasure
so
a lot of times he says you know people
don't change until the pain becomes too
great
and that's been my experience 100
as well you know it's like like i
remember when i was working on a show
full time and starting my coaching
business and i really got to the point
where i
needed to leave the show in order for my
business to take off if that's what i
wanted like there was only so much i
could do with my business working on a
tv show full time especially tv hours
you know working 8 10 hour day or 10 12
hour days um
i knew i had to leave the job
but it took me a while to make that you
know to actually make that leap you know
as ambitious and driven as i am i have
my own moments of resistance
and i
it took me time and it wasn't until the
pain became too great where i said what
am i doing i can't stay here like i have
to get out you know something happened
at work it wasn't even a big thing but
it was something that
gave me reason to leave and it wasn't
until the pain became too great that i
actually made the change
um
and so yeah so tony says that we're
moving towards pain or towards pleasure
where like there's something you want
and so you make a decision based on that
because you really want it so
i think that um
when people
you know aren't aren't making positive
changes in their life
maybe the pain just hasn't become too
great yet you know and maybe that moment
will happen for them in the future
what goes through your mind when someone
tells you you can't do something
[Laughter]
i will say that
there's like there's still a little
teeny part of me that like the answer's
first in my mind and says oh yeah
they're right
like even with all the work i do there's
still like this teeny tiny part but i i
quiet very quickly
and
um i just don't accept that for myself
i and because because there's always
going to be proof that that's not true
for everybody or everything you know
that's why i say
to look for absolutes when they're
saying words like always or never
that'll never work or you can't do that
you know but there's always going to be
an exception to that right so so i can't
i can't take that on as my own and even
if it
even if no proof existed and it was
something new that i was trying to do i
still have to believe that it's possible
i still have to get behind that
um regardless so
usually if somebody tells me that
they're either someone that i'm not
going to work with moving forward or um
you know i might try to educate them on
my philosophy you know how i view things
but
you know in the in the industry i i
still do hear it a lot
yeah
can you talk about limiting beliefs and
how we live someone else's reality this
is where i want to talk about realistic
i think that um
what somebody else deems as realistic
is based upon their belief system
and they might be limited in that scope
you know they might have a limiting
belief about what is realistic
and
the way that our subconscious mind works
is that if we believe them
that means we're deciding that what
they're saying is true
then it gets stored in a subconscious
but if we don't believe them then it
doesn't get stored in our subconscious
and so we have to get more
aware and vigilant about what we allow
into our
subconscious because if we don't we will
end up living somebody else's version of
what they think is realistic you know
based on their limiting beliefs
so for example
you know as an entrepreneur myself
starting a business and wanting to own a
home and you know in the hills or by the
ocean that's going to be a multi-million
dollar home
so if i want to
you know buy a multi-million dollar home
i have to believe that it's realistic
for that to happen i have to believe
that it's realistic for me to buy a
multi-million dollar home and the way
that i do that
is
by
looking for proof and for ways of how to
make that tangibly happen like if i can
learn more about what it takes to own a
multi-million dollar home what does my
income need to be you know i spoke to
realtors i spoke to lenders i you know i
learned about the process of you know
how much would i put down you know
people that are buying at that level are
they paying cash you know i really had
to learn all of these things and the
more i learned it the more it becomes
more realistic because i understand what
it takes right
so as i have grown as a business owner
as an entrepreneur
i started to
know people you know i started to expand
my friend base of other entrepreneurs
who are further along than me
financially right so for example one of
my friends last year just hit her first
million dollar a year
so a million dollars in a year
that's like 83 000
a month
right
now
most people would say
83 000
a month that's not realistic
right some people aren't even making
that per year
and so we decide that that isn't
realistic
but to my friend who has done it
it's totally realistic to her she did it
so her reality
is not the same of somebody else's
reality because she believe you know she
believes in a different definition of
what is realistic
and if we look at it
it's totally realistic for her to make
83 000 a month it's also totally
realistic for her to incrementally grow
every year and make more than that you
know it is not that far off for her to
make a hundred thousand dollars a month
her one of her mentors has made up to
four hundred thousand dollars a month
again it sounds like something that's
not realistic right and you could say oh
well she got lucky or she won the
lottery no they're just entrepreneurs
that learned how to build a business
and
and actually jack canfield says in that
book the success principles that a
millionaire
is made every four minutes i believe in
the united states
so it's much more common than we realize
but in our mind tells us it's not
realistic
so if i want to be a millionaire or if i
want to own a multi-million dollar home
and that means that i need to have an
income you know past a million
i can't take on somebody else's belief
that says i can't do that
i can't listen to someone that says
erica that's not really realistic right
i can't take that on
because if i do it'll never happen i'll
never get that house
so instead i have to surround myself
with people like my friend who who's
already now hitting a million dollars a
year and seeing how she's doing it and
learning from her and going oh okay
totally realistic
so i'm deciding that what i want even
though it might sound crazy to other
people
is actually really realistic to me you
know and so i i have to decide that for
myself and i i can't
base my belief
on what someone else's belief is
ah
that sounds like a nice that sounds
really nice
how can an artist ruin their own career
because they're
living someone else's fear-based reality
well
i mean with my example
of the house if i take on someone else's
limiting belief that this is impossible
i i ruined the dream by not even if i
don't even believe it could happen
i'm not gonna
learn how to grow my income i'm not
gonna speak to a lender and learn what a
lender is going to need from me as an
entrepreneur who doesn't bring home w-2s
every day every week you know like all
of that research that i've done
i wouldn't do that research if i take on
their beliefs so
you know i don't know if ruin is the
word that i would use that they're
ruining their career but i think that
they're
you're always going to get what you
believe
so if you take on somebody else's belief
that this can't happen or you can't have
that that's exactly what you will get
so
um it'll i guess ruin you know any
chances of having the thing that you
desire if you're not believing that you
can have it
how do we get in tune with our own
reality
in tune with your own reality meaning
in tune with the reality you want to
create like whatever you want to be
realistic for yourself that's true
because i guess we could get in tune
with our own reality that's negative
like basically you never want to get in
tune with your reality like your reality
is not having what you want right like
like right now in my reality i don't
have the house
so i don't want to get in tune with that
reality i want to get in tune with the
reality in which i have the house
so i mean abraham hicks talks about this
a lot but it's really about like stop
focusing on what you don't have you know
abraham says that every subject is
really two subjects the having it and
then not having it
so
if you
want to book a show
you're either focused on the fact that
you haven't booked it yet and don't have
it or you're focused on the fact that
you're going to have it
right and so one of those is the
dominant thought there and so
you don't want to focus on the reality
that you don't have it you want to focus
on the reality you're creating in the
future in the near future so you really
want to get in tune with the reality
that you want to create
you know
from a law of attraction standpoint and
you know talk in terms of like
manifesting whatever is in your life
right now you have created you have
manifested
so everything you have now is based on
things you've done in the past
and so the same for the future things
that you want is going to be based on
what you're doing right now
so what you're doing right now oh it's
talking about getting in alignment with
the thing that you want what do we do
now to manifest that thing in the future
we get aligned with it meaning we
believe that we're going to have it you
know we stop focusing on lack stop
focusing on what we don't have
and we just get excited about it we
visualize we focus on how it's going to
feel it's really about the feeling so
when when i have this job i'm going to
feel really excited and really confident
and really proud
okay well can i experience those
emotions right now
totally you don't need to book a job to
feel excited you can get excited right
you can create that emotion for yourself
so it's about like how can i just focus
on feeling excited and confident and
proud right and that is going to call
this in as opposed to if i got in tune
with my current reality where i don't
have the job i might feel sad i might
feel frustrated i might feel not worthy
right and all of those things and and
when we focus on those feelings and by
the way this is not to say that it's bad
to feel those feelings like i always
tell my clients it's healthy and okay to
feel whatever comes up for you
it's just about can we shorten the time
in which we don't feel good
and shift into feeling better so
um it's getting aligned with those
feelings and
belief in what's coming and expecting it
how does someone take action toward
their goals
when they can barely get out of bed in
the morning
they don't
i think the action that they work on is
getting out of bed in the morning
you know we can sometimes feel
overwhelmed with all of the things we
need to do or want to do
but
if you're feeling that way if you're
feeling like i can't get out of bed in
the morning
you really just want to focus on the
task at hand which is like you know
abraham talks about
um
you don't have to jump the emotional
scale so if you're feeling really low
you don't have to try to jump to feeling
amazing and going for your dreams doing
all your goals you know doing all the
actions for your goals
it's about incremental increases like
could i just feel a little bit better
can i somehow focus on getting myself
better so i feel good enough to get out
of bed
can i then maybe take a shower or could
i maybe do some exercise to get my heart
rate going and build those endorphins
and just take care of myself you know
can i can i climb that ladder
so that from here then you can feel a
little better in here and then here
right and you you're incrementally
climbing so that when you get to a place
then when you can finally start to feel
good then you can focus on
going for your goals
but i think that
you know our mental health is so much
more important than any goal
and so it's so important i always tell
my clients too like your alignment your
energy should be your priority above all
you know so if you are
feeling really rejected one day and
you're feeling really down don't go
email 10 more agents because you don't
feel good you know wait until you feel
better work on make your energy the
priority work on what can i do to make
myself feel better to shift my energy
that has to be my priority then i'll go
take those actions because you really
want to take the action from a place
where you feel good so that you get that
reflected back to you plus when you're
feeling good you'll be led to better
ideas you know when you're when you
can't even get out of bed you're not
going to have that amazing idea you know
to take some new risk and going back to
your job scenario which is a great
example you finally got this one job
which was more of a survival job and it
really helped you yes just get out of
your own mindset all this stuff and then
that's when
the re the job that you really wanted
came calling totally totally and again
that's why i say like i'm so grateful
for that waitressing job you know really
helped shift my energy and get me out of
feeling depressed and
yeah that did really good things for me
yeah what do you consider
the impossible dream well the title of
my book has that word in quotes in the
subtitle because i don't think that
anything's impossible
i really don't and i i i know that
sounds cheesy oh nothing's impossible
but
you can't think that anything you want
is impossible or else you'll never go
for it in the manner that it's going to
require
so i don't think anything's impossible i
think other people might tell you that
they think it's impossible you know
there might be
data or evidence that suggests it might
be challenging
but
any obstacle or any challenge
to me that's that's not enough
information to say oh that's too
impossible i shouldn't do it i shouldn't
even try so
yeah i don't i don't believe that
anything is impossible
how would you handle
if one of your clients was giving up on
their quote unquote hollywood dream
and you feel like maybe that's the right
decision for them
i've never felt that way ever i would
never feel that way to again though it's
not a it's not my decision it's not up
to me i you know i would never decide if
someone should go for it or not or if
someone should quit or not that has to
come from them alone
and so i would just encourage them to
get in touch with their true desires and
their true feelings to help them figure
out what's the right move for them you
know i don't think there's anything
wrong with someone saying i want to do
something else now instead like that's
okay too i mean look at me i worked in
television for all these years and then
i was like i want to coach i want to
help other people so you know our dreams
change sometimes but
i would never be the one
to tell someone that they should quit or
they shouldn't do this
have you ever seen it where someone
comes to you and they say you know i'm
not getting to
x y and d in my career and then you
realize
well this was just the total wrong path
for them no
you've never seen that no no again like
i i like i know i romanticize it a
little bit but i also think that that
is a super power like i think it's okay
that i romanticize it because that has
led to my success but i truly believe if
they have this dream then they can make
it happen
and so it's really it really just comes
back down to them having the desire if
you have a desire for a dream i will
help you i believe that you can make it
happen it's as simple as that for me
when did you first hear of abraham hicks
oh gosh years ago
i don't remember five years ago maybe i
i went to one of their live events a
couple years ago
yeah
maybe five or six years ago
and it's all about um manifestation it's
it's law of attraction you know esther
hicks channels
an entity called abraham i know that's
very weird if you're new it might be too
for you but um
but it's just information about law of
attraction where people just ask them
questions and they answer and it's
no matter what they ask it's very
applicable to anyone's what they're
going through anyone's life so
um
yeah so i've been listening for years
because it helps me and i like it
what are the big problems that are
arising for artists
during covid
and how are you helping them through it
i love this question because i have been
humbled
with the answer to this question i have
really learned a lot
i have seen proof during kovid that
absolutely anything is possible
and to me that is incredible
for i always give these examples sarah
cooper i don't know if you know sarah
cooper she's a comedian a writer
she
posted on social media these funny
videos are on tick tock i think and she
blew up and she was already like i think
she was already doing some work but she
just blew up during the pandemic
while hollywood is shut down like things
aren't even filming at all
and she ends up getting a netflix
special
and she also is invited to do the i
think the opening night monologue on one
of the late night tv shows and she did a
phenomenal job i watched it was so
impressed
it's a great example of like even when
the industry is shut down opportunities
still exist
and to me that has been so humbling
because
you know i can fall into the victim mode
of like oh my gosh this is so hard i
mean look you know my business i lost 60
of my business during the pandemic
but
i did pivot and i was like well how else
can i serve people right now how else
can i help people right now instead of
just throwing in the towel right
so i think
you know the way that i'm supporting my
clients during the pandemic
is a little different now because things
have started up and things are filming i
mean not as much as before but things
are filming but i'm really you know
empowering them to believe that their
dreams are still possible during this
time i mean there are other artists that
have you know really blown up and gotten
a lot of attention and opportunity
during this time caitlyn riley is
another example her instagram account
blew up she does this like hilarious 60
second videos that people really related
to and really loved and her account blew
up i see she getting like sponsor deals
now you know so
it's been humbling it's like erica come
on you teach this that anything is
possible and and so
um
that's been exciting for me to learn you
know like really anything is possible at
any time there's no wrong time to pursue
your dream even this pandemic i don't
think it's the wrong time
and you started your book in february
2020 yeah i started writing in february
yes wow
yeah right so i wrote a book during the
pandemic you know
yeah and now you're doing the audiobook
yes wow yes so you're basically saying
okay
one one part you know you said you're
pivoting so
at what point did you say okay i'm
showing up at the computer today to
write this first page of this book
i don't mean to sound annoying but like
i never struggled with that oh okay i
just didn't i because like when i got
the i so the idea for the book wasn't
a strategic pivoting move from the
pandemic it was just happened to be like
in december of the previous year of 2019
december
october november december is when i
started to get the nudge to write the
book
um and so i was already planning to do
it before the pandemic happened um and i
just
i talked about this in the book but it
just felt like i was divinely guided to
write this book and i had to get this
message out and so
it
it was a challenging
path in terms of like i rewrote the
first chapter 100 times you know
that it was it was challenging and
finding my voice and how i you know do i
want this book to just be for hollywood
or do i want it to be for everyone and
that was an interesting learning
experience figuring that you know
solving that problem and figuring out do
i want this message to be applicable
applicable to everyone and if i do how
much hollywood do i include how much do
i exclude
so there was you know challenges in in
that aspect but i never really struggled
with like oh my gosh i have to sit down
at the computer today and write this
right going back you said you're a
self-starter yes i i just felt very
inspired to do it but like look the
audiobook is taking me forever because
because it's so much work and i'm not
really sitting i've only recorded like a
chapter and a half so
uh
yeah
you